Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile
before my hands start shaking. No else.
You posted a question.
I'm a cybernetic organism.
Living Tissue
episode is brought to you by Athletic
Greens. I get asked all the time,
if you could only use one supplement,
what would it be?
And my answer is
inevitably Athletic Greens,
it is your all in one
nutritional insurance.
I recommended it in the four hour body,
did not get paid for that and I
travel with it to avoid getting sick.
I take it in the mornings to
ensure optimal performance.
It just covers all my basis.
If I can't get what I need through whole
food meals throughout the rest of the
day, and you can get 50 oh my
gosh, 50% off. Yes, 50% off.
If you go to athleticgreens.com forward
slash Tim that's athleticgreens.com
forward slash Tim, check it out.
It's tasty, but more important,
it will help you not screw up when
you're doing your nutritional plannings.
So for me it just covers the basis,
takes a load off my mind,
puts a lot in my body and check it out.
athleticgreens.com forward slash Tim,
thank you for supporting the
sponsors of this show. 99 designs,
which is your one stop shop for
all things graphic design related.
I've used 99 designs for everything
from banner ads to book covers,
including sketches and mock ups
that led to the four hour body,
which later became number one New York
Times Number One Wall Street Journal and
the brainstorming.
A lot of it took place with designers
from around the world and here's how it
works. Whether you need a t
shirt, a business card, a website,
an APP thumbnail,
whatever it might be,
you submit that project and
designers from around the world.
We'll send you sketches
and mock ups and designs.
You choose your favorite and you have an
original that you love or you get your
money back.
It's that straightforward and many of you
who are listening have already used it
and created some amazing things
that I'll be sharing in the future.
But in the meantime, if you want
to see some of my competitions,
some of the book covers as
well as get a free $99 upgrade,
goto 99 designs.com forward slash Tim,
that's 99 designs.com forward slash Tim.
Hello Ladies and germs,
puppies and kittens.
This is Tim Ferriss and welcome to another
episode of the Tim Ferriss Show where
it is my job to deconstruct world class
performers to tease out the routines,
the habits, the books, the influences,
everything that you can use that you
can replicate from their best practices.
And this episode is a real treat.
If you love the Arnold Sports Nagger or
Jon Favreau or Matt and make episodes
for instance, you are going to love
this one. We have a film director,
screenwriter, producer,
cinematographer, editor, and musician.
His name is Robert Rodriguez
and his story is so good.
While he was a student at
University of Texas at Austin,
he wrote the script to his first feature
film when he was sequestered into drug
research facility as a paid
subject in a clinical experiments.
So he sold his body for science so that
he could make art and that paycheck
covered the cost of shooting his film.
Now what film was that?
The film was El Mariachi,
which went on to win the coveted audience
award at Sundance Film Festival and
became the lowest budget movie
ever released by a major studio.
And he went on then of course,
to write and produce a lot and direct
and edit and so on. A lot of films.
And he's,
he's really a jack of all trades,
master of many because he's had to
operate with such low budgets and be so
resourceful. But he went on to do films
like Desperado from dusk till dawn,
the faculty, the spykids franchise, which
was huge once upon a time in Mexico,
Frank Miller,
Sin City and many others.
And the show notes of course can be
found@fourhourworkweek.com forward slash,
podcast, all the links, all
of the resources, et cetera.
Just go to four hour work,
week.com all spelled out forward
slash. Podcast. And one last thing,
very important.
Uh,
Robert Rodriguez is also the founder
and chairman of El Ray network,
which is a new genre busting English
language cable network and El Rey is
carried probably on whatever you already
have a, it's carried on Comcast, Directv,
Time Warner cable, Cox and dish. And uh,
I have watched some of my favorite
Kung Fu flicks on that channel.
I've also seen all sorts of
other action films and just,
he's a incredible gems that he has sourced
and to put on his networks to check
it out. El Ray network.
And without further ado,
please enjoy this conversation
with Robert Rodriguez.
We dig into so many
things, uh, his early days,
how he planned for low resource,
high yield movies and filmmaking,
what he's learned from Francis Ford,
Coppola, Tarantino, et Cetera, dark times,
how he's overcome them.
His parenting style has exact journaling
style and method. It goes on and on.
This, this was a real blast for me
and I hope it is for you as well.
Enjoy Robert. Welcome to the
show. Hey, how you doing man?
Great to finally meet you. Yeah,
it's great to finally meet.
And as I was doing homework for this
and trying to digest everything that is
related to you,
I checked out a couple of the directors
chair episodes and I'd seen clips
before, shorter clips, but I hadn't
sat down and really sort of, uh,
taken in three to four hours. And I
did that and I'll tell you, so I've,
I've been not having anything
to drink for the last two weeks.
And I got about halfway
through the Francis Ford
Coppola episode and I was like,
fuck, this guy's really good
at interviewing and I had
to have a glass of wine.
I didn't go too crazy.
But these episodes are such a fascinating
window into the processes of these
masters.
And I just wanted to thank you first of
all for putting them together because I
was planning on going to bed early and
I went through three hours straight.
And uh,
then I,
then I woke up and I also jumped into
this meccas episode this morning,
which is just fascinating.
And what,
what really struck me was how
different these approaches can be.
I mean there's so many ways
to skin the cat. And, um,
before I jump into
method questions though,
I wanted to ask you about your journal
and journaling because one of the
constants and all of these interviews is
the journal over and it seems like you
write a lot down and I have a
compulsive habit of note taking.
I mean if shelves of notebooks,
how do you do some handwritten do right?
I'm actually, how do you keep track of
them if you want to exit some later.
So that's going to be my
question for you also.
So I have a lot of handwritten notes
that I will scan and put into Evernote.
Okay,
cool.
Which will then allow character
recognition to pull things up if I want to
search for them. So I just have to
keep my handwriting a little clean.
But you also have really
specific in the dates,
times, places. How do you use journaling?
Journaling. Um, it's interesting
and uh, I started, you know,
with the word processing way back, you
know, when I first started filmmaking,
the first when I sold El
Mariachi and Columbia hired me,
first thing I asked for was
an apple laptop computer,
which was the very first one that came
out. They, no one knew what it was.
I was the only one on the plane with one.
I was riding my screenplays in and then
I would, I would continue my journal,
which had started by handwriting
it, it really started. Um,
I think in college my dad
gave me a day planner,
one of those day planners and
I started using it and I would,
he would write the things you're going
to do on the left side and then you would
write what you ended up
doing that day on the right.
And even though I was in college,
I tried to push myself pretty hard.
I would look and I'd go, wow, I didn't
have very much to write about myself.
At the end of that day, I'm going to have
to give myself more things on the left.
So I have mortar writes
stuff on the right.
It really made you reflect on
your day and realized I didn't,
I didn't do much today.
And so those got really full and
I became a filmmaker right away.
El Mariachi got made and the during the
process of El Mariachi, I remember, um,
keeping a really dense journal
because it was an experiment.
It was really a test film and that was
during all pro, all parts of the process,
all parts of the process.
Because I thought if I'm going
to go take on this endeavor,
I know a lot of things aren't going to
work out. It's my first feature film.
No one's intended to see it.
It's really a learning experience.
I'm just going to go make it and I'm going
to be able to look back on my journal
and see where I messed up because really
going to be a document so I wouldn't
make that mistake again.
I could go back and track why did the
exposure not work and I'd be able to go
back and go, oh, I, I didn't
do this and I didn't do that.
It was really going to be a record of
failure rather than a a document of
success in any way. It was really about
recording and methodology for a project,
a specific project.
And as the process went on right away,
as I started editing it,
I kept track of that.
I sold it pretty quickly and then I
was in Hollywood and I was like, no,
I really got something to write about.
I was writing down all the
weird stuff that was happening.
Finally I decided to put out a book on
just the making of the Mariachi and I
kept journaling from then on,
everything which was rebel without a crew,
rebel without a crew.
And I would find that you meet the
same people over and over again.
Like I wrote down very specifics that
people that I would meet casually and
Hollywood knowing we would run into
each other again and they ended up being
great collaborators 10 years later,
you know,
or showing up in things and I'd be able
to go back and read them stuff from the
early days and they would blow them away.
So when you write these down,
for instance, don't go into computer
so I can find them and I do my year.
So do you do it by hand and then
input it into a computer? No,
I do them all on the computer.
So I have a little alarm that goes off
at midnight to make sure cause in nights,
which leave your time and I'll write
something down because I found that even
when I just wrote some items down I could
go back and fill them in later cause
you would remember and it
would always would shock me.
What kept it going is when I would go
back and review the journals at how many
life changing things happen,
like within a weekend or things that you
thought were spread out over two years.
We're actually Friday, Saturday,
Sunday and that Monday,
I mean so many occurrences happened
in chunks that blow you away.
Things that kind of define you.
And do you use a word,
do you use a different application?
How do you can always just used word,
cause I was the first thing I had on APP
apple laptop. They're about a thousand,
sometimes 1,002 thousand pages
per year. Wow. Of journals.
Few days or I'm sorry, a few
pages per night on average. Yeah,
few pages per hour. Sometimes
some, some hardly anything.
Some things are bigger and sometimes
I'll clip sometimes of the cheek.
Sometimes I'll clip like reviews or
conversations I had that had been written
down. Some rest and I'll throw them in
there too. Everything goes right in the,
in the right date.
And so I could search by date.
Then I can kind of cross reference stuff,
which is,
I would just say for anyone
who's a parent, it's a must.
It's a must because your children
and you forget everything, you know,
within a few years they'll forget things
that you think they should remember for
the rest of their lives. The Lord
remembered if three and forced and I'm an,
I'm a real family man,
so I really love every birthday I'll go
tell my kids again because they forget
by the next year what their
first years were like,
cause I'll just read those journal
entries and it blows them away, you know?
Or they'll say, hey, we should go
camping again. I go camping. Oh yeah.
Remember that time we went camping and I
put the tent in the backyard and it had
electricity going through.
We had fans were watching Johnny
quest and we were playing.
I must have journal on that
and it must have video.
So I would go year by year. I just
searched camping, camping, camping, no.
May 4th, 1999 we went
camping. Oh it's on tape.
25 of this particular tape.
I'd go find the tape and show it to them.
I've tried show him the tape.
It didn't have to go camping again.
They just relived,
they're reliving the day we lived it and
they met and it was better than we even
remembered. So capsulated and
stuff like that is really,
really important.
It reminds me of something I don't
think I've ever talked about,
but my mom, when I was 15, I
spent a year abroad in Japan,
was my first time overseas
and I was in Japanese school.
It's the only in a where's Waldo
American kid in the entire fucking, yeah,
I think it's 5,000 student school,
Japanese family.
And of course I assumed at the time I
was going to remember everything that
happened,
but my mom,
to her credit every time we had a phone
call would get off the phone and write
down what I had said.
And so she has this record
of my experience in Japan
that I have no record of it.
Of course. I don't remember any of it
without that kind of queuing. Yeah. Uh,
the part of that came through,
I read them a diary.
My mom tried to keep if when
we're at a really though,
and it had very few entries,
but one of the most defining moments,
which she pushed me into a pool because
I wouldn't go jump in and she knew I
just needed to push and I felt
totally betrayed and angry with it.
It was in there, but it had her side of
the story. And of course it was correct,
but I wish she had written more. So I
thought, I'm going to make sure I write.
And uh, and now it's become an addiction
and that I, and it's just so necessary.
I mean,
you ask her girlfriend or your wife,
what did we do last year and your
birthday. Then remember a year goes by,
you will not remember the details.
You go back and you see the journals.
It's even better the second time you
lived it again and you realize the
importance of it.
And when you meet someone you think might
be a recurring figure in your life or
you meet someone who ends up
being a teacher of some type, uh,
how often do you go back and
review the notes or do you,
is it really just in time information,
not just in case. So when you,
when you realize, oh my God,
I'm going to be meeting,
say Francis Ford Coppola
for the second time,
should probably go back and look at
what happened in the first meeting.
Or is it something that you proactively
review when you were sort of a,
it's only on a need to know cause
there's so many things you mean you're,
you're really,
I tried to tell myself I want to be
the guy looking through the windshield,
not the rear view mirror,
but sometimes you,
you can see better through the windshield
if you looked through the rear view
mirror and look at some of
this stuff that's gone on and,
and seeing kind of make sense of where
your relationships are going or what
you've learned.
And it blows me away sometimes.
I'll just go ahead and look somebody
up that I haven't, you know,
that I'm about to meet with. Uh,
I just met with Jim Cameron, uh,
when we had always talked like four hours.
We hadn't seen each other
in a few years and I was,
and I looked up old stuff and I was like,
oh my God, do more when we did this,
this, cause I met him 20 years ago and
we'd been friends over the years and you
totally forgot when I went and showed him
Desperado for the first time before it
came out just to see what he thought.
He's watched it in a screening room and
he gave me two though manuscripts here.
Why, why watch your movie? You go
read a couple of my treatments.
One of them was for Spiderman and one of
them was for Avatar. This was in 1994.
Wow. That's how long ago he had that I
have and how much that was going on in his
head. And I thought, wow,
to keep something that was that visionary
and your head that long waiting for
the technology to come,
those kinds of things made you realized
some of these projects I've had for 10
years, I should go. We bring them
back up. I wonder. And I have,
I have since then dusted off something
that I'd had 15 years and sold it and now
I've just finished a screenplay for it.
So you mentioned Jim Cameron.
I had an opportunity to,
I met him very
briefly through the x prize and
Peter Diamandis and those guys.
And as part of the experience, because
it was a fundraiser for the x prize,
we all got staff or crew
shirts from Avatar. Right.
And the shirts said,
uh,
it's said something along the
lines of hope is not a strategy.
Failure's not an option. Luck
is not a factor. And Jim is,
is known for being very demanding.
Not in a bad way,
but I thought that shirt was
just why it spoke volumes.
I think that in so many different ways
about sort of his process has mentality.
How do you keep morale high
when you're working with a crew?
And maybe like you said,
you're doing like an exterior shot in
Austin and people are just suffering and
sweating fatigued.
Uh,
w w w do you have any tricks or approaches
that you use over and over again to
keep kind of morale high and
get the best out of people?
I've worked with the same crew for some
of them for 20 years and so they kind of
know already the
philosophy I tend to have,
and I've learned this not through
filmmaking, but through other disciplines,
sometimes working with painters and
sculptors and musician friends. Cause uh,
what I found, it's kind of why
I do so many different jobs.
It's because creativity is,
and job specific. I mean,
if you know how to be creative,
you can literally jump from job to job
with no training and do them pretty well
because the technical part of any
job is 10% 90% of that is creativity.
And if you already know how to be
creative, you've kind of got the battle,
you know, half beat, which
is you don't need to know.
You don't need to know
what note specifically.
You're in a play when you get onstage
and do your solo. Everybody will go,
what did you just play and you're going
to go, I don't know. Yes, I just, to me,
fun that. How do you know what
you're playing? Just know.
I don't even know when I played. I
was like, well, it was fantastic.
Anybody tape it? No. That's another one
that goes up into the air. You know, ask,
ask any of the greats, you know,
painters. I studied under a painter.
Sebastian Kruger went
all the way to Germany.
He had to watch him paint to figure
out his trick. How does he do it?
Because I tried to do what he did
and it just looked like garbage.
He must have a special brush.
You must have special paint and a
special technique and going, no,
he's just doing,
he's talked to live mid tones,
starts knocking into my lights a little
bit on the Chin and he goes to the eye
and I'm like, how do you know where
to go next? He goes, oh, I never know.
It's different every time it drives me
bonkers. So how come I can't do that?
And I'd go sit down and suddenly
I could do it. It blows you away.
So I take those lessons back and I teach
my actors that I teach my crew that.
So just to it.
You don't need to know.
Yeah, there was some, sorry to pause,
but this is so fascinating to me. Uh,
so what clicked what, what did you, what
was the realization when you sat down,
you get it in your own way, thinking
that you needed to know something,
a trick or a process before it would
flow if you got out of the way,
it would just flow with what gives
you permission to let it flow.
Sometimes if you take four years of
schooling are you study under somebody,
then you've suddenly given
your permission to let it flow.
And I know you're a guy who likes to
take a shortcut in, here's the shortcut,
just get out of your own way,
right.
You just opening it up the pipe and that
creativity flows through and as soon as
your ego in the way and you go home. But
I don't know if I know what to do next.
You've already put I in front of it and
you've already blocked it a little bit.
I did it once,
but I don't know if I can do it again.
It was never you the best you can be.
It's just to get out of the way.
So it comes through. So when an actor
comes to me or a crew member, he goes,
I'm not sure I know how to play
this part or I'm not sure I know go.
That's beautiful cause the other half
is going to show up or were there,
they say knowing is half the battle.
I think the most important part
is the other half. Not Knowing,
not knowing what's going to happen,
but you trusted it will be there.
When you put the brush up to the canvas,
it's going to know where to go and the
further you're out of the way of it,
it'll just happen. So the trust
comes first and trust comes first.
You have to trust first
and then it'll happen.
And I always pointed out when it
does, you know, like I pointed out,
you'll see it and I'll point it out when
it's going to fall on your lap or I'll
just call upon you to come
up with something and you
will and I'm going to point
out cause that's the magic. You just
going to be open to it. It's all attitude.
There's nothing wrong
that could ever happen.
I remember on from dusk
till dawn to film the Ex,
the special effects guys put too much
fire and explosion and the actors can run
it out of the building and the,
it's in the movie.
You see that the building blow up the the
bar at the end and the fireball if you
were to continue,
but I cut away.
It just kept going and engulf the
whole set and that was the first shot.
We still needed lots of other stuff to
shoot with him and we're like, okay,
everyone else is freaking out.
The production designer of the cry
and it was all their work. And uh,
me and my assistant director, he came
over and he goes, you think what?
I'm thinking, yeah, it looks good
the way it is. It's all charred.
Let's just keep shooting and
we'll do the repair. But you know,
little pair of needs to be done for next
week and we'll shoot that exterior next
week, but let's just shoot
this. Just keep shooting.
Sometimes you use those gifts because
nothing ever goes according to plan.
Sometimes when I hear, you
know, new filmmakers talk,
they talk all down about their film.
Oh well,
nothing worked and it was a
disappointment. It's like,
oh, they don't realize it.
That's the job. The job is that nothing
is going to work at all. And you go, well,
how can I turn that in a way to turn it
into a positive and I get something much
better than if I had all the time
and money in the world. Yeah.
And I loved those experiences
so much that I would purposely,
and I talked to Michael Mann about this
then in Michael Mann director's chair,
cause we talked about Manhunter once
years ago and he tells me the story and he
didn't have any money.
He'd fired the effects crew.
It's some of the really cool staccato
editing was really to cover up the fact
that they didn't have effects
that I didn't know that.
I always thought it was a
stylistic choice. He goes, no,
it was because we didn't
have any money or time.
And I had the commas cutting into myself
and I was throwing ketchup on the guy
in between. And then I did
it edit like, oh my God,
I thought that was
brilliant stylistic choice.
Oh I said I'm going to do
that for all my movies now.
I want all of them to
not have enough money,
not enough time so that we're forced to
be more creative because that's going to
give it something to spark and you can't
manufacturer and people will tap it or
they'll go, I don't know why I liked this
movie. It's kind of a weird movement.
There's something about it that makes
me want to watch it again and again
because it's kind of life to it. Sometimes
art is should be imperfect in a way.
The point you made just a
minute ago about creativity,
transferring from one area to the
next two seemingly unrelated skills and
areas I think is really important and I,
I cannot recommend highly enough that
people check out the director's chair. Uh,
one of the,
one of the terms that jumped out,
which you kind of mentioned in your
last example was the Gremlins, right?
And the gremlins that
you kind of turn to you.
How do you embrace the Gremlins and
turn them to your advantage and the,
you know,
the example of the ending of back to
the future and how like the church tower
and all of that was because the studio
is just refuse to finance this more kind
of spectacular ending
things that you would think that planned
for for a year were created at the last
moment.
And I couldn't believe that myself.
That's why I enjoy doing those interviews.
I truly want to know these things
cause they still blow me away.
The creative process blows me away and
it applies to so much that even if you're
not a director or a filmmaker,
you watched that and you see people
talking about the creativity and creative
process and you see how it
applies to anything that you do,
how you raise your children, how you cook
food, how you run a business. You know,
creativity is so much a part of that.
And when people say,
Oh you do so many things, you, you, you
musician, you're a painter, you, you know,
you edit your, the composer, you're the
cinematographer. The editor is saying,
you do so many different things
go, no, I only do one thing.
I live a creative life.
When you put creativity in everything,
everything becomes available to anything
that has creative aspect is suddenly
years to go and do and there's no
separation between work and play. I mean,
I work quote unquote in my house.
I mean that's why I write my scripts,
come up with my ideas while I'm playing
with my kids while I'm cooking them.
A meal, which is a creative exercise. Art,
you can eat and itself and then you
go upstairs and do some editing.
Do you edit a Cgu? I can already
hear the kind of the music for.
I'll walk over to this room
and I'll do music for it.
I mean then you go and I'm
not sure how that's character.
I'm going to get into this character said
maybe I'll paint him first and kind of
see visually what he looks like or
musically what he sounds like and you can
work completely nonlinear that way because
you realize I can do anything I want
because everything can be creative.
Even the business call, suddenly you go,
this is kind of out of my league,
but let me have my creativity to it and
maybe that'll solve something no one
else will be able to solve.
And sure enough,
you can always rely on creativity
to sort of win the day.
And in a lot of areas
with say El Mariachi, I
do, I've heard numerous,
a couple of different versions
of this, uh, financing,
but I'd love to know how you
financed it because, uh, uh,
I've heard experimental
medical procedures,
I've heard telling your sort
of body to science. So what,
how was that financed?
Yeah,
that's been one of the strangest things.
The legend kept growing around Mariachi
and is one of the few times you'll hear
a legend where it was all
literally true. I mean, it was, uh,
it was this crazy as it sounded,
but back then, you know, I mean,
I was from a family of 10 kids.
There was no borrowing from mom and dad
to go make a movie. This, that was on me.
Um, I was already paying my way through
school and I already had two jobs.
I had a job as a cartoonist and I had a
job working at the university and barely
making rent tuition. So to
go make a movie, even though,
you know, people would say, oh, 7,000,
that's so cheap for a 16 millimeter movie.
Hell yeah, you got $7,000 sticking
out of your pocket. Who has that?
So you had to kind of take down a score
and the only way you could actually go
do a big number was to go to this.
Uh,
it was one of the biggest universities
in the country at the time.
They had this thing called a Pharmaco,
which was a medical research facility.
And it's only like a fourth stage where
it's already been tested many times and
this is the final before they get FDA
approval, they're not, they're not like,
you know, mixing a couple
of things together and give
it to you and saying, okay,
let's see if it works.
They're really kind of seeing then you,
but they need healthy young specimens
between the ages of 18 and 24 and so
that's college students
and they all need money.
So you go in for a weekend and make 500
bucks, which we go about picking cushion.
I would go in there for the longer ones.
There were like a month where you would
be paid for your time rather than your
pain. So I'm, I now it writes grants
while I was in there and you make two,
2000,
$3,000 in a month.
Real money when you're not having
to pay for food and rent anything.
Now you have to eat. You were housed
there, your house there. Yeah,
your it and you can't leave and you've
got to eat and Shit and pee at a certain
time and benefit though, right? Because
you're there covering some of your,
what would otherwise be expensive.
It was a great deal.
And so I did a couple of those and uh,
one of them was a drug
that's on the market.
Liberatory the cholesterol lowering drug.
That's the one I was on.
So I got to eat bacon and
high cholesterol diet.
I used that money to go and make the film
because I had an idea we could sell it
for at least double of what we made it.
If we kept the budget really low,
I didn't know.
So I had to just make it for as little
as possible and most of that money went
to just the film stock and I,
and I really didn't think
anyone was going to see it.
It was really just a test film.
That's why I did it in Spanish.
I did it for the Spanish market.
I was already had a bunch of
award winning short films,
but I needed to practice telling features.
So I thought,
let me just make a bunch of features
for the Spanish market just to get some
seasoning, do all the jobs myself
because I couldn't afford a crew in that.
We all learned them all. If I can
sell it for twice of what I put in,
that's like the best film school,
I'll learn every job.
I'll do like two or three of these things,
cut them all together,
take out the best portions
and use it on my demo reel.
And then use the money that I
make to go make a real first film,
English language,
American independent film.
And the first one got released by
Columbia pictures and I was shocked. Now,
how did that,
how did that happen and who took a
chance on you or how did you increase the
odds of that hip happening? Because
I guess it was Sundance. Is that,
was that the trigger? No, it
was already bought by Sunday,
was already bought by Sun. So how
did that, how did that happen?
I had this crazy idea.
I had made this short film by myself.
It was a windup camera. It was eight
minutes long. It's called bed head.
It's online and I utilized it to use slow
motion and all kinds of things that I
couldn't use on a video camera.
I really wanted to show off what I
could do with that little camera,
a world world war two camera. They'll
wind up ones, I mean a piece of job,
but it could do stuff that couldn't do
with video shot that put it in festivals
and won a bunch of festivals
and I was like, wow.
I did that all by myself
with $800 it's eight minutes.
If I did that times 10 I could do an 80
minute movie for $8,000 or less cause it
would be dialogue scenes. It wouldn't be
walled wall action like that short film.
I could pat it out.
I could probably do it for five grand.
I felt like I was getting away with
something and coming up with this idea I
think and how come no one's ever done
this before? Let me go try it this summer.
And we try for the Spanish video market
cause they make them for like 30 grand.
But I'll guarantee no one sees it. I'll
call it El Mariachi, which is basically,
if you're going to the action section,
you won't buy a movie called rent
a movie called the guitar player.
That promises no action at all.
But I just thought, you know,
I had a sense of humor and I thought let
me make it kind of didn't really want
people to see it. I just want to
be able to test out this, these,
these ideas and see if it's possible.
Shot, shot, shot, cut it, cut it, cut it,
went to sell it in la because that's
where the distributors were for those us
distributed Spanish language movies
cause he would just look at the video box
and all the companies were
like on Wilshire Boulevard.
So I drove up here with my friend Carlos
and the in I had was there was going to
be a 25th anniversary of the Texas Film
Commission in Austin and a bunch of
people from Hollywood that governor
Ann Richards was trying to invite in.
And I saw the list of people and one of
the agents from ICM called Robert Newman
was going to be there and I thought maybe
I can try and slip on my short films.
Well the whole thing got canceled and
it fell apart. So when I was in la,
I called ICM up cold. I looked him
up in the phone book, called him up.
This was in 1992 and got an s for Robert
Newman's office and they put me right
through, he was in new agent there.
He didn't have any directors yet.
I called up as, as an assistant and I
said, hey, can I talk to Robert Newman?
He was gonna, he was gonna come
down to this 25th anniversary thing.
And they said, oh yeah, I went up on
the phone with him. He said, yeah,
what happened with that? I was already
to come down and go, wow, I don't know,
but I was going to show you
my film and I'm here in town.
I wanted to drop off my award,
winning each short film and a trailer
for a movie and made for $7,000 okay.
Drop it off. I couldn't
believe it. I dropped it off.
He called me back up the next
day. Hey, the machine ate my tape.
He actually watched it completely. I went
and made another tape, gave it to him,
waited over the weekend. And
uh, he got the call and he says,
I love the short film, but I love the
trailer to trailer for this movie.
The mariachi movie, it's, it's,
I mean it's like a worldclass
trailer cause I kind of,
I know people come and watch the
whole thing. So I was pretty,
I'm a pretty good editor.
I cut this really snazzy trailer that
just made you want to watch the movie.
And he said, how much does it cost again?
Said 7,000 well that's pretty good.
Most trailers costs 20 or 30 no, no,
the whole film costs. I'll come on,
I know the whole thing. I shot it. I
shot a real budget but I'm going to,
can I come up and talk to you?
So he had me come up and I told him I
plan on making two or three of these,
like a trilogy of these guy with
a guitar case as just a test.
And I'm wondering what else I should
put on my demo tape because you know my
word winning short films been doing well.
I think it was all Kinda like a dollars
trilogy and I can get you work right now
if this is a really cause yeah,
it's in this to the studios.
Just put subtitles on it and I'll send
it to him. So I subtitled it, send it,
and he got me a two year deal right away
at Columbia pictures. Not to remake,
not to even release Mariachi.
Mariachi was just a calling card,
but it happened to so quick. I mean I was
really young. I was, what, 22, 23. Um,
I really thought I was
going to make some tests,
films first and have a chance to come
up with what my big idea was. I mean,
and I was in no rush.
I really wanted to be prepared.
I really wanted to learn every job
and really know what I was doing.
So this suddenly caught me by surprise
because now they're asking, well,
you're a filmmaker now.
And he even wrote me down as a writer,
director and I guess a writer, director,
I guess I wrote the script. So I mean,
I guess I'm a writer, director. I never
really thought of myself that way.
And I was suddenly this young kid plunged
into this world and I suddenly had to
come up with a bunch of original
ideas because this was my shot. I've,
it was too quick. It goes not
prepared. So I thought, well look,
you guys liked the Mariachi.
Why don't we just remake that?
We make it with like Antonio
Mendez in Spain and we'll,
we'll just cast it up and just read me.
They said, okay, that's a good idea,
but we want to test screen and Mariachi
first to make sure people aren't linked.
It's a downer. And when the girl gets
killed, so they made a film print,
they tested it and people
liked it the way it was.
They decided to take it to festivals
and I completely protested. I was like,
this is my practice from,
no one was ever supposed to see this.
Give me $2,000 put Tom Ball.
Don't put this out for the oldest.
If I knew people were going to see,
give me $2,000 I'll go reshoot half of it.
Just knowing people were, we're going to
see it as my first film. And they say, no,
you don't know what you
have here was very special.
And they took it out and it
went to Telluride, Toronto
and the, the head of, um,
Sundance came to me at Toronto and said,
don't show it at any more festivals and
you can bring it to Sundance and put it
in competition because he know he
knew it would do really well there.
And it was an hour.
So I was already bought by Columbia,
so I was one of the few films.
Usually it's already had a
distributor and we took it and um,
I had a great little talk
I would do before to set it
up cause I had to disclaim
why it was the way it
was. And I said, well,
when you see the Columbia logo come on
in the front at local probably costs more
than the whole movie when
everything you watch after that,
just know that I how I did it.
I wanted people to know how I did it.
I really wanted to deconstruct how it
was done because I would have wanted to
know that as a film student who felt
coming from a family of 10 kids living in
Texas, people constantly saying,
you want to be a filmmaker? Oh,
you need to move to la.
They should stay where you are and come
up with something that would could be
sold. I wanted others. I just wanted to
get on top of a mountain, tell everybody,
so I just why I put out a book and that's
why even before each screen I would
explain how it was even possible because
I knew they would be wondering because
nobody had really ever done it. It wasn't
that it was impossible, just nobody.
He had done it before. No one ever thought
that way. People kind of forgot that.
That's how movies really started.
It was always like a couple of guys with
a windup camera and Buster Keaton in
front. It wasn't a business
yet. When it became a business,
suddenly everyone had a job and you
needed 200 people because it was now an
industry, but that's not what
the art form was originally.
It was just the manipulation of moving
images and you can do that with two
people. One person that was a breakthrough
idea and so by Amy would tell them,
I just took stock in what I had. My
friend Carlos, he's got a ranch in Mexico.
Okay. That'll be with the bad
guys at his cousin owns a bar.
The bars was going to be
the first initial shootouts.
We're going to be all the bad guys hanging
out. His other cousin owns a bus line.
Okay. There'll be an action
scene with bus at some point.
Just a big action scene in the middle of
a movie with a bus. He's got a pit bull.
Okay? He's in the movie. His other
friend had a turtle, Eve Valkyrie,
the turtles in the movie because people
will think we had an animal wrangler and
that also suddenly raise production value.
So I wrote everything around what we add
so that you never had to go search and
you never had to spend anything on the
movie. That movie cost, really nothing.
It was really just the, the fact that
I wanted to shoot it on film, um,
instead of video so that it would look
more expensive and try and tell people,
you know, made it for 70,000 and
tried to sell it for like 70,000 set.
It ended up going to Columbia getting
released and that story really, um,
when we won Sundance,
the audience award, uh,
my acceptance speech said you're going
to get a lot more entries next year when
people find out that this is the one
that won a movie made with no money,
no crew,
everyone's going to pick up a camera
and started making their own movies and
it's been flooded with entry
since then. It was really, um,
a real change in the paradigm
and it was only out of necessity.
It wasn't my big idea that it could
be done. I really just thought,
I don't want to take anyone with me and
my best friend wanted to come help on my
movie shoot from Mariachi.
I said Nah,
cause I got to go to Mexico
and this camera I bought it.
You know it's probably going to break
down the first day. I don't want it.
I'll jinx it if I start bringing too many
people down and I don't mind failing.
I just don't like feeling at a bunch
of other in front of a bunch of other
people.
So when they go back and they say,
Robyn tried to make a movie for no money.
Yeah idiot, you got stranded in Mexico.
I really didn't think it would work and
I was surprised and that's the best I
tell people is just be naive. Stay
naive, throw it away. Don't overthink it.
I didn't overthink it at all because
I would have treated it completely
differently had I thought I would
ever even show it to anybody had,
I thought it would go to a festival
and I would have submitted,
I would spend 10 times as much.
I would've gotten a borrowed
money and dental instead.
It was like one take one take,
one to everything was one take.
Even if it didn't work,
because I had the film's so expensive.
So I would go and it was a noisy
camera and it was a soundless camera.
I mean it would make so much noise.
You couldn't record sound.
So I had to record sound the way
you're doing right now. Right.
So it should to take, put the camera away,
get the sound out. Put the mic up close.
So it's for those people.
Yeah.
We have two mikes attached
to a little recording device.
I would put the mic as close as
you have it. So I got great sound,
but it was out of sync. But
you kind of talk in your own
rhythm. So if you say, hi,
my name is Robert, put the camera
where you can not do the audio. Hi,
my name is Robert. It kinds of comes,
I can pretty much get it. Let's see,
cause I don't like rubbery lips.
If you look at Mariachi,
it's all in sync except where
it started to get out of sync.
I cut away to the dog or I cut away to
a closeup and it created this really
snappy, uh, editing style.
But it was really just to get it back
and sync cause I couldn't stand that.
But that was the whole idea
of, you know, it's like,
let me just try and do all these things
myself and see if we can put it together.
And he reminds me of Jack Ma.
I mean,
it's very consistent among these people
who seem to come out of nowhere and
build something very big. Of course there
are exceptions, but Jack Ma of Alibaba,
I said, you know, we had a couple
of advantages when we started.
We had no experience,
no money and no plan.
And so every dollar we spent, we had to
consider very, very, very carefully. Well,
my plan was I had a really good plan.
This was the plan was I'm going to go
shoot one take of everything because the
film is the most expensive item. If
I just shoot two takes, you know,
one just in case I've just doubled my
budget. So one take, I'll cut it together.
The stuff that I need to come reshoot,
we'll call only reshoot that
will only get those shots.
He never come back and reshoot.
By the time you get back up
there and back to Austin,
you figure out a way to cut around
things that were like not done right or a
little slow or,
and I never came back and reshot anything.
He ended up just working with what
you got but it, but it left me off,
got me off the hook from
being too precious is by
knowing I had that safety net,
which I never ended up using. So if
you can do that for yourself, you know,
in any area that you're in, try to just
go free with abandoned. And sometimes,
you know, they say that for writing a book
or writing a script, just write, don't,
don't keep rereading each page and
going, oh, it's not good enough.
And then tear it up and throw it in the
trashcan. You'll never get anywhere.
You've got to just have get momentum
and keep going and then come back later
with fresh eyes and look at it again.
Now that you have access to
so many resources, how do you,
what are practices you have or
principles for maintaining that scrappy,
creative mindset, right? Because if you,
you don't have to have many constraints
if you don't want to. Yeah. At this point.
So are there ways that you try to
simulate that or was it a couple of things
with that? This is freedom
of limitations. You know,
there's almost more freeing to know I
got to use only these items to turtle bar
ranch. You almost completely
free within that, you know,
you almost can do not anything because
that would be almost too many options.
But you're, you're, you're
just put into a box.
It's one of my favorite movies I did
with Quintin was called four rooms where
they said we were all doing short films,
were all have the same criteria,
has to be set in one room,
has to be New Year's Eve,
and you have to use the bellhop.
The freedom of limitations was enormous.
I mean you watch that short and it goes
all over the room and by the end we
burned down in the room.
I mean it's,
it's a almost with some more exciting
to know that you were in a box and you
could be creative within that box.
So now that so many things
are available to you,
you wouldn't limit yourself in a way.
So I try to limit time.
I try to limit money so
that we can really get,
still keep that essence of
creativity and deliver on the screen.
Something that just looks much bigger
so that you can retain your freedom,
creative freedom.
Because if you start spending more money,
suddenly the financier's, rightfully
so, the studios are, you know,
the executives will be over your shoulder
constantly questioning every move you
make because they want their money back.
But if you keep the budget low,
it's a win win situation.
If the money to the movie does great,
it's a great success and
the movie doesn't do great,
it's still a success because it didn't
cost very much and it'll make back its
money over time. That's kind of
where I've kind of lived and breathe.
I'm about to jump out of the box a little
bit more and do some things that are a
little bigger just to,
just to learn more.
You cause you just learn more when you
go and do other kinds of assignments.
But where it's really the most
fun and that's why you asked,
how do you keep the morale high?
The morale always high on the set because
they know we're just being creative.
That's the name of the game. It's
not looking for a result. It's like,
how can we just keep
ourselves jazzed about this?
If you were to go back and rewrite a
rebel without a crew at this point,
what would you change? What would
you add? What would you remove?
No, I haven't read it
since I wrote it. Actually,
it's really funny that you
say that because the people
come up to me a lot with
copies ready for me, like to sign it.
It's a lot of people have read it and,
and um, and they say that to help them.
And even if they weren't a filmmaker,
you know, helped me open my own
business and help me do this. And um,
and they would mention a
quote and I'm thinking,
I don't remember ever saying that. I
gotta go reread it. I was smart back then.
What happened?
I said some really good stuff.
I didn't say give me these quotes
that sounded like I got to follow the,
I need to go reread it just so I can
go follow what I used to tell myself.
Because there's something
that happens and you know,
when you go to lecture
or when you go to teach,
it's kind of like you opening
up that pipe, you know,
you go to talk with the intention and
it's all intention based of giving.
People who are looking for answers
and looking for strategies, uh,
something they can use and
out of your mouth will come.
Things that you are then
going and Caribbean and
writing down your self going,
well that's pretty good advice. Where'd
that come from? You know, that's,
cause it's like you're letting
it flow. It's not you, you know,
you've gotten out of
the way at that point.
So that book was a very much like that.
You know,
there's a lot of things in there that
even I'm surprised popped out that seemed
right at that time that were very knowing
without me knowing anything. You know.
So, um, I, I really do like that about it.
I wouldn't think I
would rewrite that book,
but I'm trying to figure out is how to
write the ones after because so much
happened after that and the diaries are
so dense that it's almost hard to know
how to focus. I think I
figured out how to do it. Um,
by doing a creativity based book where
anytime some of these events happened to
do, particularly with
creativity or the process,
then those things like hanging out with
Jim that time or doing this with this
person,
what would fit into it.
And then you could get some of those
journal entries in a way there was organic
to the whole creative processes. That
seems to be mostly what I'm about now.
Not specifically film related,
you know, because I would,
if film died tomorrow,
I would be sculpting or painting or doing
music or something else that involved
creativity. So really
what I, what I am as a,
as a creative or someone who lives a
creative life, not even just in your work,
but it's also in when he's not working,
working. And you, you mentioned
earlier two jobs, uh, in college.
One of them was cartooning. And
was that Los Hooligans? Yes. Okay.
So you had loose hooligans,
which then became later the name of the,
of your company,
which was changed. I've kind of
two questions. One is how did cart,
how cartooning helped you in
your various creative endeavors,
but maybe specifically film and you know,
did you use your kind of a drawing ability
for say El Mariachi or any of these
others? Uh, then the
second question, which we
can get to, but it's why you changed
the name to trouble maker studios. Um,
well but that's the first one. First
Lyssa logins. Yeah, it was, was a name.
The these little troublemakers is about
the little kids based on my family in
the,
in the comic strip and a loss hooligans
was to show that there were Hispanic,
you know,
um,
it was with the few Hispanic strips and
that through that paper was a very big
paper and we had a big comics page,
was very popular,
very famous people came out
of their birthday. Brother
came out of there, Chris,
where it was a Pulitzer prize
winning. Cartoonist, uh,
has amazing books out here.
Most of that,
it's a lot of that first early work
he did was from his college work.
I mean he is just bonkers grade and
made everyone around them. Good.
That's the other thing is if you
surround yourself with masters,
which is I still try to do,
that's main trick is even when we're
filming I'll have master painters and
master sculptors and master come visit
so the artists can just get off on what
they're doing and apply it to their area.
Cause it's like you're,
your mind explodes and you want to always
be training and always be learning.
And um, and that's kind of
what that page was for me.
The cartooning made me realize a
lot about the creative process.
I remember I used to come home and I'd
have to do a strip a day and it would
take sometimes three,
four hours and I would sometimes it does
not feel like facing the blank page.
I would go lay down and go,
I'm,
I'm trying to figure out if I can create
this method where I can just come lay
down and stare.
At the ceiling and it'll just appear
fully formed and then I can go and draw it
and it never could get that to work.
I'd be running at a time,
I'd run back to the table and I'd
realize the only way to do it is by just
drawing.
You'd have to draw and draw and draw and
then one drawing would kind of be kind
of funny or cool and
that was kind of neat.
This one kind of goes with that and you
draw a couple of filler ups and that's
how it'd be created.
You had to actually move and I
applied that to all my other work,
filmmaking and everything.
Even if I didn't know what to do,
you just had to begin. And a
lot of people, that's the star,
the part that keeps them back the most.
It's like,
well I don't have an idea so I
can't start. It's like, no, you,
you'll only get the idea once you start.
It's totally reverse thing.
You have to act first
before inspirational hit.
You don't wait for inspiration and then
act or getting everyone to act cause
you're never going to
have the inspiration,
not consistently so you can consistently
perform and act and get there and sit
and draw till it comes
out and it comes out.
And if you trust it and then
you get out of your way.
And it started teaching me that too.
You don't have to ever sit there and go,
well I don't have any ideas.
I don't know if I can draw in a day.
Get your ego out of it.
It's not you anyway. If you
sooner you shut up to center,
it'll come through,
get out of the way,
let the pen glide where it needs to go
and it'll be there and you'll be amazed
and you'll be going,
how did I do that?
Creative spirit will be like
pastor taking credit for it again.
But uh, that applied to that,
um, to everything that I do.
And sometimes it helps to be able to draw,
to show somebody really quickly,
this is the shot I have in mind.
Let's go get this. And I'm,
and I be able to sketch it out so that,
so that would help. But um, mostly, uh,
it was really just a process to create it.
What I learned about the creative
process that early, I was like 18,
19 at the time. Um, I'll show you
some of the strips. They're pretty,
I looked back at him and I'm
like, oh my God, I cannot,
I drew better then than I
do now or what happened.
But because I was practicing every
day and that was the other thing.
It showed you mastery. You know, if you,
you spent four hours a day on anything,
you're any, a brief freaking good. Even
if you haven't zero talent. I mean,
one of the cartoon is it Chris, where
came in one day, he goes, oh my God, it's,
my teacher told me this.
You're trying to have jumped and
leaps and bounds within a day.
It's not a gradual up. It's like
suddenly from one day to the next.
And I just saw that in years,
I had done it strip that
was really different from
anything I did and it went to
that level. So, um, I
apply that a lot to people,
like don't get frustrated to keep
going, keep practicing, keep adding,
can put in the hours and
then it'll come to you.
And then at one point
suddenly you'll beat.
And I've had it happen everywhere and
sculpting and music and film making where
it's suddenly it's just
jumps, jumps, yeah.
At jumps by a lot and it blows you
away and you're like, what's different?
Nothing's different. I just kept
applying myself and had finally,
and it finally clicked, troublemaker
studios came from, I had the studio,
I didn't know what to call
my production company.
I was an independent filmmaker who was
getting to put his company in the front
of a credits. So I had just come up
with a company. I didn't have one.
So I just use those hooligans so people
would know it was the same guy who was
making cartoons and then, um, but
the cinnamon was kind of cool.
I hadn't quite figured it out.
And then one year was in 1997 I was going
to go to Europe to do some publicity
and I went into this place where Stevie
Ray Vaughan used to get his cowboy hats
and to get a cowboy hat. And I walked
into the, to their place and they said,
I need a cowboy hat because I'm going to
Europe. And every time I go to Europe,
they always ask, you're from
Texas where he was a cowboy hat.
So I'm going to go in there this time
with a cowboy hat. It's like, guys,
what do you got right now?
And the guy ran to the back and he
looked at me that kind of size you up.
And they, uh, Texas hatters and they
fit something to your head and he goes,
this is called a troublemaker.
Troublemaker. Wow, that's
a cool name for a hat.
Shit, I'm going to call my studio
that troublemakers two years.
It's kind of the same as less
hooligans, but done in a, in a, in a,
in a really cool way. So yeah, my,
my thing of wearing a cowboy hat and
the name of his studio was born that one
day. Well I love her, I love it.
I've,
when I've made companies like LLCs or
whatever and I'll be on the phone with the
lawyer and they'll say,
well what do you want to do with such
and such name isn't available and I'll
just look around where it
happened to be sitting.
Kind of like the Kobayashi moment,
the usual suspects and I'll be like,
it's a pillow serious,
you know,
just tagging things together round
and that's all be like try that.
No one's going to have have,
I've already read
one of my favorite LLCs and this is the
sentiment that sometimes why you go,
and you probably can relate to this
sometimes when you try to get help from
people and they don't quite see the
vision. And then as a negativity involved,
one of my companies is called nevermind,
I'll do it myself productions.
And it always the motivates
people when you want to say, Hey,
can you take me this or bring
me that? And they go like, well,
I don't know if that ain't go, never
mind, I'll do it myself. Productions like,
okay, okay, I'll go dog with it.
They don't want to be labeled that.
It's like a great motivator.
Uh, so speaking of, of trouble
maker, um, and just being,
say rabble rouser,
one of the things that I wrote down
from your conversation with Francis Ford
Coppola, who by the way, he, so he
owns a bunch of, uh, obviously he's,
he's spends a lot of time in nor cal.
He's got,
the winery also has some restaurants and
so everyone said I for about a year I
was writing and I just went
to his restaurants hoping
that he would walk in. Uh,
it was in north beach. I was
right at the corner. It'd be,
I think he owns the entire building.
But um,
the restaurant that I went into most is
actually in Palo Alto and I'm blanking
on the, on the name. I want to say
Blanco. It also, I thought, I thought,
I thought it was like white and red,
but I would go and I'd sit in there just
in the off chance that he would walk in.
Never. And never ended up
happening, but I never gave up hope.
And that's why I wrote,
actually I probably edited half of the
four hour work week in that restaurant.
Uh, drank way too much coffee. But one
of the things he said was, you know,
failure is not durable. And uh, the
segue there, the next thing he said was,
the things that they fire you for when
you're young are the same things they
give you lifetime achievement
awards for when you're old.
And so I wanted to know what,
what did you get and how did you get
yourself in trouble in the early days?
Were there,
were there ways that you got yourself a
sort of created friction or conflict in
ways that you don't regret
or that you do regret?
Yeah. Oh, that was anytime you step
out of line, you know, like that,
but it wasn't in the g in trouble,
but you just have people not understanding
exactly what you were going to do.
And then with good intentions not want
you to go like down the wrong path.
So I remember one of my teachers who
became a great friend of mine, I wouldn't,
he asked me, what are you doing this
summer? I'm going to go make a movie.
And so Mariachi the going, what are you
going to do? I'm going to go make a movie.
Oh yeah. Who's going to be your GP? Oh,
well I'm going to be the defeat. Oh No,
the actors will hate you. You'll be there
setting up the lights the whole time,
you know,
right away.
So I'd tell me all the disadvantages
to try to do something yourself.
And so I just like, I'm not gonna
tell anybody what I'm gonna do.
I'm just going to go do it because I have
a feeling it'll work and if it doesn't
work, no one, Lou. And it worked.
When I came back and I showed him,
he felt very embarrassed,
but he goes, well, you know,
you hate to see these kids go out there
and you know, with good intentions.
But you know,
anytime you just did something that was
against the grain because he'd just go,
I don't know. I have a, I have a
feeling I should just go this way.
You should just go and
try it. And um, it's just,
it's good not to follow the
herd, you know, go the other way.
If everyone's going that way, you go this
other way. Yeah, you're going to stumble,
you're going to stumble up,
but you're also going to stumble upon,
you're going to stumble upon an idea. No
one came. So my favorite quotes, I say,
that's great.
It's going to be my book talks.
And people get all excited because
it's like, you're going to stumble,
but you're going to stumble upon something
no one ever else came up with because
it's the freaking lined with gold
over there. No one goes that way.
It hasn't been picked clean yet.
And you're going to stumble upon
something and you'll stumble a few times,
but then you're going to,
you're going to consistently stumble upon
an idea no one's come up with by going
that way. And so I tend to just kind
of always been that way. I was like,
if everyone is going that way, like they
know what they're doing with purpose,
I don't know what I'm doing,
I'm just going to go this other way.
That way at least it's a new frontier.
And I always found success that way.
I always found success by
just going the opposite way.
If it was too much competition over there,
if everyone is trying to get
through at one little door,
you're in the wrong
place. You know? And I,
and I hate saying that sometimes
I a film festival and people say,
how do we break in and go, well the
problem is you're at a film festival.
Nothing wrong with film festival,
but everyone else here is trying to get
through that same door and it does not
all going to fit.
So you've got to think bigger than that.
There's less competition up there.
So instead of everyone,
I always wanted to get into TV,
but instead of going and
competing with everyone else,
trying to get on 7:00 PM on NBC
on a Friday night on a network,
you know how many other people are
trying to own a network? Nobody.
You're competing with no one and
you're competing with, you know,
literally when that network that I got
was up for grabs because of this you El
Rey, it was a hundred other applicants
know that sounds like a lot.
But at the whole country,
a hundred really how many actually
had probably a solid business plan,
an actual vision of something
that could be able to bet.
It's probably five him with a
top five instead of the top,
you know, 20,000 trying to get an on
NBC Friday night and Saturday night. Um,
so I always say, you know, try to try to
just look, you know, bigger than that.
And I feel failure. That's what I
talk a lot about. Director's chair.
Why was bringing that up with Francis?
I like talking about mistakes and
failure a lot with these directors cause
people tend to think,
they just make no mistakes ever and
ever think that that's a bad cause.
I used to think the same way
when I went and did this.
Why did Mariachi by myself? I didn't
want to see people make me make mistakes.
I didn't want them to see me make mistakes
cause I thought it was a bad thing,
but it's not. You learn so much no matter
what. Even if I didn't sell Mariachi,
I would've learned so much by
doing that project. That was a,
that was the idea is I'm there alert.
I'm not there to win and there to learn
because I know when eventually you don't
have to win. Right now she's got to
know I'm going to go do follow my heart,
go that way. And sometimes it'll work for
you. Sometimes it will be the godfather,
sometimes it'll be one from the
heart. Sometimes it'll be, you know,
apocalypse now, sometimes
it'll be Jack, you know? No,
but you've got to keep going that way.
And that's kind of what he was saying.
You know, sometimes failure,
if you have that attitude,
well maybe in 10 years
this will be a success.
It helps a lot to have that
kind of history. You know,
when I'm to make a movie,
if it didn't do well, I would go, hey,
maybe this is the thing. You know,
John Carpenter made the thing and it
bombed. Everyone thought it was terrible.
They call it pornography.
They thought it was he and buried his
head in the sand for 10 years until 10
years later they announced that it was
a classic and it was a masterpiece.
Of course he, he was wallowing in despair
for 10 years. Thanks. But you know,
it came late, but, uh, eventually
it would come and if it doesn't,
if you're already on to better things,
so he's,
as long as you always
think it's not a bad thing,
I try to always look at failure as
a good thing. You know, failure.
That Winston Churchill quote, I like, um,
success is moving from one failure
to the next with great enthusiasm.
You should just be willing to
go fail. Cause I mean, you're,
you're going out that way.
Yeah, that's different.
You're going into uncharted territory
and that's where you'll find eventually,
you know, as long as you're learning
something, you learn something.
And sometimes the only way to get across
that river is by slipping on that first
rock. That's the way there.
And when you get to the side,
you look back and sure enough,
I could only have gotten here had I done
those things. And people sometimes say,
I remember when I was giving a talk like
that and I had a gal see holds up g and
she goes, okay, well you're a
real positive, but what do I do?
What do I tell myself when I just
wasted a year and a half of my life on
something that didn't work? I said,
well, it's a real negative way to put it.
Can you rephrase that for me?
I learned something the hard way.
I learned something good to
heartbreak that still sucks. You know,
you gotta be able to look at your
failures and know that there's a key to
success and every failure.
We looked at the ashes long enough,
you'll find something. I'll give you one.
And I did four rooms. Quintin asked me,
do you want to do one of these movies?
One of these short films called four
rooms, but the one with the bellhop,
the one in a hotel room and my hand
went up right away. Instinctually. Yeah,
I want to do that. It's an
experimental film. Um, I'm there now.
Should I have answered so quick?
Should I have been a little more studied?
Should I have gone back and researched
and realize anthology movies never work,
even when it's Scorsese and woody
Allen and Coppola, they bomb miserably.
They never work. Should I have researched,
come back given a different answer.
No one could answer that. I think I
know. I would still go with my instinct.
The movie bombed in the
ashes of that failure.
I can find at least two keys to success.
If I look back on it on the set,
when I was doing it at
cast Antonio Banderas,
it's the dad and had this cool
little Mexican kid as a son.
It looked really close together and then
I found the best actress I could find
was this little, you know, half
Asian girl. She was amazing.
So I needed an Asian mom.
I really wanted them to look like a
family and I got this great little family
and it's New Year's Eve because I was
dictated by the script so they're all
dressed in Tuxedos and I was looking at
Antonio and his and his Asian wife and
going, wow, they look like this
really cool international spy couple.
What if they were spies and
these two little kids who
can barely tie their shoes,
didn't know they were spies.
They get captured.
They have to say my thought of
that on the set of four rooms,
there's four of those now and a
TV series coming. So that one,
the other one was after it failed.
I thought. I still love short films.
Anthologies never work.
We shouldn't have had four stories.
She'd have been three stories cause
that's probably three acts and it should
just be the same director instead of
different directors because we didn't know
what each person was doing.
I'm going to try it again.
Why on earth would I try it again if I
knew that they would don't work because
you figured something out when
you're doing it the first time.
And that was sin city. So spike
here, Denson city came out of that.
So you can always look back.
If you have the positive attitude,
you can look back at what your, that's
why what Francis saying it's correct.
Failure isn't always durable. You can go
back and you can look at it and go, oh,
that wasn't a failure.
That was a key moment in my development
that I needed to take and I can trust my
instinct. I really can.
Because what is success?
It's not necessarily measured in dollars.
It can be measured and knowledge.
You know,
what did I learn that I can now use later
and I may take me 10 years to figure
it out,
but it'll be there when I need it and
then I'll be able to look back and check a
journal and go, Oh yeah, this,
this and that equaled together.
I'm going to keep that.
I'm going to keep following my gut.
And it's a Mecca said the same thing,
but he should not have
even hired Eric Stone.
He knew it was supposed to be Michael J.
Fox separate your intellect
tries to tell you different.
Your intellect tries to tell
you you can make anything work,
but your gut is harder to explain to
people because it's just a feeling.
You can't always go to a studio and say,
I know,
but I just have a feeling that
would be like, what does that mean?
But that's the dilemma being an artist,
which is why I've always
kind of chosen low,
low budget movies so that people
don't have to ask me those questions.
I'm in charge so I can just go,
you know what? If it feels good,
it is good and that's
where we're going to do.
What books or book do you most
frequently gift to other people?
I spread out there recently.
It's been some years,
but for a while when
that book start with why,
start with why I liked that one a lot
because I'd seen the little talk on Ted
talk,
Simon Simon Sinek did and um,
and now it's in that to people and go
look at this is this is so important.
You know,
I realized better what I was doing when I,
when I read that book and I gave it
to people to show them how to look,
clarify what they're doing right
and what they're doing wrong.
And it was a very simple approach that
they should kind of take every day.
And like if you go to an actor and say,
Hey,
I'm a filmmaker and I'm making a low
budget movie and I kind of need your name
as a marquee, kind of helps sell it. Um,
I can't pay very much and it's going to
be a probably a lot of work. But, um,
if you want to be in it, you know, you're
thinking about all yourself. It was like,
no,
get the hell Outta here.
Cause they're just only talking about
is what you do and how you do it,
which is I make a low budget movies. Yeah.
So what it means, you've got no money.
All right? Instead, I always start with
a why I go to them. I love what you do.
Always been a big fan.
I've got a part that you never would get.
I believe in creative freedom.
I don't work with the studios like
work independently. I'm the boss there.
Just me and my in my crew.
It's a very creative, um,
ask any of your actor friends,
they'll say, go have that experience.
You're just going to feel so invigorated.
I should very quickly.
So you'll be out Robert Deniro
in machete in four days.
I'm going to shoot you out in four days
while you'll be on your next movie for
six months.
Your mind movie for four days and it's
gonna be the most fun you've ever had.
And probably you'll get probably great
reviews or performance is going to be
just really free because I'm going to
give you that freedom. That's why I do it.
How do I do it? Well, I work
very independently. I have
very few people in my crew.
We all do multiple jobs. We do it with
less money so that we have more freedom.
What is it that we do?
I'm an independent filmmaker.
Do you want to come make this
movie? They're like, yes.
Because it's all about what they can
do, what they can bring to it, what,
how it's going to fulfill them. You don't
have to mention, oh, and by the way,
I need your name is on the movie because
really you really are interested in
their talent and it does bring a, you
know, a level to the, to the picture.
He really got to think about why, why is
it that I'm even doing what I'm doing?
One of my favorite things that I read,
and I hadn't realized this backstory,
but was your experiences since
city and Frank Miller and uh,
the,
well up maybe battle is too strong a word,
but the decision to insist
on the co-directing. Right.
And could you just elaborate on that
for folks because as its context, uh, I,
I don't know if I mentioned it before,
but I have about 10,000 comic
books at home, all poly.
So I was a comic book addict for decades
and I want it to a comic book penciler
so it's actually an illustrator and in
college for one of the satire magazines.
But I wanted to be a comic book penciler
for a very, very long time. I could you,
could you give a little bit of the context
around sensity city and a and how you
have a little context and just in
the battles that you normally have
when you try and step out. And I'm
like, how do you get in trouble?
Like you're asked,
how did you get in trouble all the time?
It's never intentional.
It's just sometimes you're
just ahead of people's time.
So when Quentin and I were making
these movies, like for, um,
even I'd have to deal Mariachi, I
went and did some other films and,
and uh,
I didn't know if I knew I wanted to join
something like the director's guild.
And it's nothing that I dislike more
than organizations cause they're usually
the most disorganized. I think it's called
an organization. You already know, okay.
They have other things in mind.
It's probably doesn't involve me and it's
suddenly I'm in a box and I want to be
in a box and George Lucas isn't in the
director's guild and neither is Quinn.
So I'm,
I'm just stay out of the director's guild.
And then they'd come after
you after a little while ago.
It's embarrassing that you're out making
films and, and you're not in the guild.
Um, so I said, okay, well I can't,
I can't really join because I
wanted to do low budget movies.
Y'All don't have low budget in agreements.
You know, this is kind of my lifeblood.
This is how we came to kind
of go do whatever I want.
And so what we were
putting some paperwork in,
they were putting some new
roles that allows that.
And so I did a film and they made me join.
So I joined in the very first film I
go and make under, it was four rooms,
which already didn't fall into their
guidelines already had to quit again.
I said it already cost me like five
grand to get into the damn organization.
So it was like, okay so, Oh man, now
I'm already get out. All right, I'm out.
I'll just stay out.
I knew it and it's not going to fit me.
So we go in and make movies for
years and years and they let me go.
They let me go. Cause it
was like, all right, really,
how long has this guy's
career going to last?
And then like four or five films later,
they come back because it's
becoming embarrassing that
I'm working and no longer
in the guild. And they, and you know,
it's all about their faith
and I'm an Hispanic filmmaker,
which they had very few and I'm not
in the guilt. So they, they, you know,
coax me back in. I said, but I am
only going to go back in. And I said,
if you don't go back in, we're going
to make harder for you to get a job,
you know, where the other one. So I was
like, Ooh, I was gonna get to that. Okay,
well I ain't freaking pain again, so
you guys didn't have to pay me in. Um,
because you know, all, you know,
you know, whilst on your deal.
So I went back in and I was always getting
in trouble because I would be like,
these organizations don't like hyphen.
It's so if you're like a writer
and a director and editor,
they like having their name
more prominent than the other.
So the writer's guild would be upset
at director's guild of me as a writer,
wasn't more prominent than do,
I mean this stuff that you just
don't care about at all, you know,
you're just trying to make your movie.
And so I remember having to leave like
the writer's guild actually after spykids
because they demanded all kinds of stuff.
And then, um, the directors guild again,
um,
was giving me hassle over having a
credit that said shot chops scored and
directed by Robert Rodriguez. And
once upon a time, Mexico was fine.
I just had to separate the door.
I didn't want my name to come up 20
times cause I was doing a bunch of jobs.
But you know, but each kilo that
makes you put your name in there.
So I tried to combine, you didn't want
12 concern raise with your neighbor?
I think he wanted me to separate it
so my name would keep coming back up.
But he just looked like, you know, really
you get tricycle? It was like, no, no, no,
no. So here I am. Plus I did the
buoy so fast. I didn't really,
I'm not the cinematographer main,
I just shot it and it wasn't,
I wasn't thoughtfully editing new man.
I chopped it and I, I did the music,
you know,
I can barely play and it's an orchestra
but I scored it and music composed by
Robert G, you know, it's like cut out all
the lofty things. They didn't like that.
So I was always having to go in front
of the board for something. And, um,
and then when sin city came around, that
was like the final Straw because, um,
I thought,
and it was happened very organically.
I went to see Frank Miller and I showed
them this test that I did for sin city
and I said, I know what it's like
to create original characters and,
and not to trust Hollywood,
but this isn't Hollywood.
This is something totally different.
I made this on my own and I'm
going to offer you a deal.
How about I'll write the screenplay,
he'll be unremarkable cause I'm gonna
copy it right out of your books.
It's a November.
I'll have the screenplay by December.
We'll go shoot a test in January.
What should the opening scene and I
have some actor friends come down.
We'll shoot it, I'll cut it. You'll be
there. You'll do direct with me. Um,
I'll do the effects, I'll do the
score, I'll do the title sequence,
Vic title sequence with all the actors
we want to be in it and not have those
ended up being in it. Like we
put Bruce Willis, you know,
Mickey Rourke started putting
names in the fake titles.
And if you like what you see,
we'll make a deal for the rights
and then we'll make the movie.
If you don't like you keep it as a
short film. You can show your friends.
So we did it and he went for it
and I had said, is there any,
you're amazing director, but you're
using a pen instead of a camera.
I mean the performances you
get out of your paper actors,
I would love to have you there. Do you
want to direct one of them? And he said,
I've always wanted to
do big fat kills a man.
You should be there for the whole thing.
You and me, we should direct it together.
I'm really just copying your
thing right out of the book.
I really want that just to move.
So we should direct this together.
Because you were, I used
to be a cartoonist. I know.
It's the same freaking thing.
It's the same thing.
He was telling stories visually.
You're already doing it and when you
go to Hollywood they think of you less
because you're coming
from the comic world.
They don't realize you're telling stories
visually better than a lot of them.
So I want to put you where you belong.
You're at that same level.
You'll walk in and you're already going
to be directing it at the same level as
another director at telling
you that's what it is.
Cause I know I jumped around all these
jobs, they're all the same creatively,
they're all the same. So he came and
did it and we're getting ready to go.
And like a week before production
directors guild calls, Oh here we go.
I'm in trouble again. I don't even
know why. And then calmly said, well,
office big time.
They call and they say,
you're very aware of our rules.
What rules?
They haven't broke book like this thick.
Like I sit there and read this thing.
It's like a phone book. What role is
that? Did you can't have two directors?
How's that? I see two directors all
the time. Which housekeeper? Brothers.
You know the Cohen Brothers? Uh,
you know the Hughes brothers? No.
They were a teen before they joined the
guild. What? What does that mean? Well,
one of you can't direct this movie and
one of them has to produce and the next
movie do together you can direct together
cause then you would have already
established a working relationship. You
have to be what's called a bonafide team.
Really. I mean I don't
think that's going to fly.
I mean why do I even go into the guild
and you already just going to tell me
what to do. They said, well we think they,
I think they thought I
was doing it on purpose.
I really didn't know that was a rule I
could, you know, it's just so convoluted.
It seems like so selective. I said, I
don't think anyone will know that we,
me and him have never worked together in,
couldn't you qualified somehow and say
well if you're also the writer, director,
editor, composer, you
can also do this for now.
So I,
and the day it was there suggested that
I should leave because they thought I
was a trouble maker. Right.
They said, we think you should.
You should believe the guild.
If you're going to do that,
cause we would now allow you to do it.
We'd have to shut down the movie.
I was like,
well,
I'm gonna go ask frank because I know
we don't want to shut down the way frank
wouldn't. How about you just
be the director? I mean,
they don't care if I direct,
I can direct. I just can't be a name
of director. They don't care. I mean,
some of these like, you know, uh, Peter
Jackson does the Lord of the rings,
like five directors, but only one person.
They only want one person credited.
You know,
cause he can't be in all the sets.
He has to have other directors out
there, um, with actors, you know,
but they want the illusion
that has only one director,
which isn't always the
case. And she said, I just,
I just realized is that why when someone
guessed directs a certain scene in a
movie, that's why you only see one
name in the credits. Yeah. Uh, so,
but people don't know that the audience
doesn't know or care about their stupid
rules. So I said, no one's gonna know, but
anyway, okay, whatever. So I was frank.
How about I just produce and you direct
by name? You know, I'll be there.
We'll direct like always, they don't
really care that we both direct,
even said even both directive you want,
but only one of me is going to be credited
and I just don't like people giving
you rules that are just made up
in a box somewhere. You know?
I just always rub against that and I just,
I just don't, I just don't like that.
I just get breaks down the freedom and
the spirit of what you're doing and they
don't understand it and they're
just usually behind the times.
Like when we did that four rooms,
but they didn't have,
they didn't know low budget movies.
We're going to come in with like a storm
like that and they weren't prepared.
Eventually they came around
but they weren't ready then.
So you just have to leave until they
can get their shit together. So, um,
this was another case like that.
They came back many times,
beg and it turned out very bad for them.
They got so much bad press. So anyway,
they said, you know, hey, you should
just leave. I said, okay frank,
what do you think? How about I
produced you direct? And he goes,
well that doesn't seem fair,
so right. What should I do?
And Frank said, well, on my,
on my tombstone it will say it does not
play well with other kids. And I said,
me too. Oh yeah, I'll just going to quit
all of that. Right. I'm out of here,
I'm quitting. I'm going to stick by the
artists. We're going to do this together.
And, but when we don't have
to tell anybody, it was just
keep it under the radar.
I'll just leave quietly. I was
always out of there, you know,
several times and make any noise.
They leaked it to the press,
they leaked it to the Holly report.
They write my production, you know,
I guess the screw up my production, they
did it cause I didn't tell him. I don't,
I'm not in Hollywood house.
Would they know unless they went near a
leaky faucets and told everybody and it
when it flipped on him.
Yeah. It turned really bad.
Suddenly everybody wanted to be involved
in this movie that was a renegade or
the director was,
you know,
supporting the artist vision so much
that he gave up residuals ever chance of
getting an award. You know, you just
give up so much by leaving the guilt. Um,
and, and they got beat up in the
press for years about that. That um,
for the same reason you
said, yeah, you left the,
it became such a badge of honor to the
left for the sake of this other artists.
And when I'd go to get actors,
I would show them that opening scene and
the fake credits. I'm like, Bruce Willis,
his name was already in the credits,
you know,
but he's a little tour and they would go,
I gotta be in this movie.
I'm already in the credits.
And then plus what's going on with a
Gillen and Frank's really co directing and
he's sent is so exciting.
You know,
actors gets so into something that's
pure and passionate and about the product
only in the business. Damn the business
and all, I can go to hell. Oh man,
they just jumped on that train so fast.
And so we had so many great actors jumping
on board and it, and it was, you know,
a big, oh, so then this is the big joke.
Here's the topper is now I could do
anything I want with the credits. Yeah.
So not only is it directed by
Frank Miller and Robert Rodriguez,
I had Quinten come directive one scene,
special guest director,
now that looks like an official title.
Now these guys over, they're like, aw,
they're whole illusion of a single
director just been squashed by a big movie
called Sin City because they
wouldn't play freaking ball.
So now people think that's a
genuine title. But wait a minute,
it's a special guest director.
Real Tice and no, I made,
I know that's my creation and quit
because they went to Clinton of all people
because he wasn't in the guild either.
Um,
so it turned into this really funny
thing. So for years, you know,
they would come back and say, you
really should rejoin, haven't,
haven't had to rejoin since.
What they don't want.
And this makes sense is they don't want
like some producer to go to a director
and say, well, I'm going to be your
co-director. I won't finance the movie.
You'll see how somebody could
abuse that can be turned around.
But that's clearly not what this was.
But that's why the rules were so strict
and that's why they didn't want to bend
the rules and they thought, you
know, I was such a troublemaker.
Better to let him leave. And I thought
so too. Why, why fit me in that box?
I don't belong in that box.
I'm always going to be doing something.
Where do you want like just let me
go fly free. So, um, it's really,
you know why that
happened? But uh, it again,
you'll run into resistance if
you're going to go that way.
Everyone else is trying
to get in the guilt.
You're actually trying
not to get in the guild.
You end up on the island of misfit toys
along with George Lucas and Quentin
Tarantino. I write, Jim
Cameron came over to the table.
I was sitting with George
Lucas was talking about, I'm
not come out of the guilt,
I'm, I'm, I'm like George
George left the guild long ago,
if they were bashing him for credits
and things that he was doing in the star
wars movies that were really cutting edge,
that they all ended up
changing their roles to later.
But back then he was just so
pissed. He Lash, it's not a fit. It,
it's not a fit for everybody,
especially if you're a really odd,
you should just be allowed
to go out cause you,
it is odd d to do that many different
jobs. But that's Kinda how I started. Um,
even when I went to do Desperado,
I remember telling him,
I want to edit this movie
as well. And they said, no,
we've never had a director edit his
own movie, just not done. And I said,
well I edited Mariachi and you
bought that. They're like, okay,
you can edit it, but you have to edit
here in la so we can watch these.
We don't think you know what you're doing.
And it's up top set the precedent.
And they showed the, I showed him the
first scene that cut and they were like,
okay, okay, you know what
you're doing, you can cut it.
So they were really supportive
after that. But at first it was, um,
anytime you do something new, you kind
of have to break a precedent in order to,
and once you got the precedent set,
then you can just do it. You do want.
So now you go into a studio and
they go, oh, that's that guy. He,
he shoots his own movies. He had his
own movies, he scores his own way.
That's just how he works.
Um,
it would be harder later in life to
be an established director and say,
suddenly I want to edit my own film and
ride and everything on. And I don't know.
Yeah. He just can't say that we're
going to have to set that precedent.
So that's what was a really,
was the great thing about El Mariachi
is that it set a precedent for me doing
every job if I wanted to solve as
it became available to me later.
Yeah. I'm known as a, I
could say affectionately,
but I don't think it's
terribly affectionate. Uh,
I'm known as a problem author in
publishing because I, uh, have,
uh,
I've,
I've sketched out and then hired my own
artists and designers to do the covers
for instance. I mean that's like
one of several dozen examples,
but you kind of have to start
fighting early. Uh, and uh,
then even though they might not
accept your terms, all of your terms,
uh, the expectation is set. So it's
not a, the resistance, it's not futile,
but it kind of lessens over time it seems.
Yeah,
I've done all,
I've done it all my posters
since Desperado Cause Don
Desperado the same thing.
They send a,
and it's not like the studios doing it.
They send an agency down anyway. It's
not like it's their guys agency shows up.
Antonio was sick that day and they're
like, oh, what do I want to hear?
Only one day it's,
we'll just,
we'll put his outfit on one of the other
crew members and then we'll paste his
head on later. Like, that's
not going to look right.
Nobody moves like him. Oh Geez,
this is going to be awful.
So we shot our own poster on the set of,
at the famous one of
him with a gun the side,
because I saw him doing that one
day on the set and I thought,
well that's kind of a cool button.
I went,
took a little snapshot
and that's kind of a,
that'd be a great poster right there.
And when we went to go show the studio,
the posters they put up, they look like
DVD covers and one's the other guys did.
And I put mine up there
too. And um, Lisa Henson,
president of Columbia looked at all of
them and she looked at the one that I had
there and show that you liked
that one. And I go, that is mine.
And then she looks at me
like, Oh shit. And I know, no,
I wouldn't have said that was
really, oh, we didn't know.
I'm glad I just put it up there along
with the others, didn't say anything.
And then that set a precedent. From then
on I could go to every studio and go,
I do my own posters too. So you guys
can go ahead and try and make one,
but we'll try and make one.
And the key is also to do it early.
Do it like while you're still shooting.
First impression is everything.
I'll cut a trailer while
I'm still shooting and send
it to the studio Delco and
try and make their own over and over.
And they can't get that first
thing they saw to the head.
They can still not as good
as the one we saw it. Right?
You've already done or he stuck it in
there that's jammed in there and it's
never going to be right. And it's
happened consistently again and again.
That way that you put in that first,
you know, it has to be a good idea.
At first it was a good idea.
If it's terrible though,
they'll do better than it.
You mean you'll agree,
you just thought about who's winning.
You just don't wanna be
stuck with a bad poster.
So at least you have something that you
really like in case with all their team.
They don't come up with something.
And that's always kind of been the case
with us because you're just coming from
it from a point of view
that's different. I mean, I'm,
I'm shooting the poster
while I'm shooting the movie.
I have a set up on the side.
So if we have Robert Deniro,
they're only for four days. We're not
going to get them later to do a poster.
That's what they all do.
That's why they don't look anything like
they do in the movie and the posters
because they haven't thought of that
concept yet. They do that much later.
I do it right then on the set,
I'll pull them over to the green screen,
shoot amazing photos of him,
like in,
in character with all my
actors and I have him.
So when I go to make the posters for like,
since he's not in the
middle of another movie,
it's like from the moment of they
were filming and it's like they're in
character and it's then it's perfect.
It's really great.
And you couldn't get a better
performance out of them.
They're not trying to remember
it later where they were. So, um,
that's been a big plus is just having my
own production studios in Austin where
I can just have it a studio
that just makes sense. You know,
it's just like streamlined and it's
outside of the business. So it's really,
you question everything that doesn't work,
come up with a new way that
works better for today's Times.
And that's kind of how we've been able
to pioneer a lot of things like digital
photography way before anyone was shooting
digital first digital three d movie
was spiking Spaghetti,
um,
doing like full on green screen movies
like probably gets three years since city
was really, uh, we pioneered a lot of
that down there when I was reading,
reading up on your bio
a couple of times in,
in a few different sort of
versions of your bio it said.
And then he took two years off for then
like few paragraphs down and then he
took three years off and came back with x.
Uh,
where are you actually taking
time off and if so, just what,
what's, what takes place? What do you
do in between big projects? Sometimes?
Um, some, some years are
more active than others.
I remember one year I did a
shot, um, once upon a time,
Mexico spike gets to spike. It's
three. And then once upon time,
Mexican came out, I had shot all these
movies that were all like sitting down.
I'm kind of at the same time
cause they weren't doing it.
Some of them have release
dates that are later.
So even though I shot once upon time,
Mexico in 2001,
it wasn't released until 2003.
So sometimes the look like there's an
activity when you're actually working on
something and then sometimes the movie's
done different parts and it sits there
and then it's,
you know,
if they think the release dates better
six months later and then that pushes it.
So, um, sometimes it'll look
like there's bigger gas,
but usually consistently I'll shoot
between one and two movies a year. Got It.
That was very consistent.
I can't eek out books, uh,
at any faster than like one
per three or four years.
I just don't have the stem and uh, uh,
what's, this is a question I'm, I'm,
I'm stealing from your interviews
in the director's chair,
but what seen have you taken the most
takes of work shots seen at taking the
most takes of takes, excuse me, yet,
you know, it's different. I don't,
I don't shoot, um, I should
very differently because, uh,
I've always thought as an editor
because I started that way. In fact,
that's why they didn't want me to cut
desperado they'd saw the footage and it
didn't look like daily
footage they normally got.
We're usually someone walks in the room,
they come and sit down,
they do the whole scene and you cut me.
I would only shoot him walking in the
room that I would cut cause I knew that in
the wide shot,
that's all I was going to use because I
was already seeing how it was going to
edit it. And so, um,
it almost couldn't be edited by anybody
else cause I kind of only shot it one
way. So, um, and that's just
because that's how I learned.
I mean I used to cut in the camera.
I know Mariachi that Cameron was so loud,
we make it sound like that. It sounded
like all your money was going away.
So I would call action. The guy would
start running, then I would start filming.
So cause the first startup, I'm not
going to use action. He starts running
cut. I wouldn't shoot through
the action and kind of,
I would just shoot the
little portion that has.
So I was literally shooting my edits.
So I don't, I'm not as extreme now,
but I won't,
I won't ever do more than a certain
number takes because as an editor I've
already seen what all use, um, where
sometimes somebody will shoot thinking,
I gotta make sure the editor
has enough to work with.
And so you're covering your way over
covering it where I'm getting only
specifically what I need,
I can move so much faster because I don't,
I don't need that. Let's say it's
a problematic shot. Like the,
the one that Quentin brought up that
was 34 takes or whatever it was.
We was trying to get like the blood and
the Chinese condom to like pop up over
the shoulder.
Oh yeah.
Well quizzes and very old school and he
wants to try to do as much in camera and
no CG where I would just do a CG fix.
God, it's so like when I showed him, uh,
since city first time,
um,
and he sees me Ho she cuts the guy's head
off and the blood sprays her face and
her eyes don't blink. He was,
that's an impossible shot. And I go
and I said, I don't know,
but I shot it twice.
So I shot her once with her eyes open,
no blood on her face.
And then I had her close her eyes
and we sprayed it with blood.
Of course she flinches he goes, she
didn't flinch at all. It goes what?
She flinched.
But I cut that out and I left her eyes
open from the take from few seconds.
Previously it's, but that's impossible.
So it was impossible, but not for her.
She can do it.
A normal person can't help but flinch
when they get some thrown in her face.
But she that character can the
actress camp but the character can,
I said Samson,
I'm talking about and we can do,
you can actually be more not more true
to the character using the technology
cause you're trying to tell a particular
story and give a story point across
that if you don't,
sometimes embracing technologies is
good but he likes to try to get it old
school. I would never have done that. I
would have been like one take. All right,
we got CG here,
go ahead and spray the bloods.
We have a real reference of what it looks
like and I can either combine it or to
really see, cause I don't want it to look
like CG. Let's shoot it, the real bloods.
We can see what it would look like in
this light and then we'll, you know,
you just don't have to have all
the components simultaneous.
Right, right. Got It.
And that's why I sometimes think with
the Squibb you put a squib on somebody's,
what's a squib a Squib as an explosive
that makes lawyer bullet hole and I'm in
here, we get the timing right. Especially
if you show emotion or something.
Cause by the time the actor reacts to
the fact that he just got shot and then
does the body movements did that delayed
so you never see it on camera cause you
when you're editing you'll cut to
the point where it's going back.
So you have to put that in digitally
anyway. Right. Or something, you know.
So I anything I,
my crew already knows Robert doesn't
like anything that requires a countdown.
You have to go like all right
everybody ready? Three, two, one pop.
That means that some kind of an explosive
or some kind of a square or some kind
of gag that's probably not going to
work up doing, having to rewire it,
do it. That's why he was there so long.
Cause then once you just go in and going,
now it's like point of no return.
We might as well keep going.
We're committed now and then, uh, I just
can't, I don't have that kind of money.
What is it? Actually, let me, let
me, let me pause on that question.
So one of the things I've really enjoyed
reading about or reading this is just
my reference, I read so much, uh,
watching and hearing about in
the Quentin Tarantino interview.
I think it might've been part one was
talking about how he in the novels that he
enjoyed or like the Elmore
Leonard, I think it was, uh,
they were non consequential. Right?
And that you would start into you,
you have something like
reservoir dogs say, uh,
that starts in media arrests.
They would say in a,
in writing like right in the action,
which is something I do a lot and in my,
in my own writing. And then, uh,
you'll see how he would sort of take the
best elements of a novel and create a
cinematic version of that.
I was just so happy to see
the way you did sin city.
I mean, just like I love graphic novels
and there's so like you said, I mean, so,
uh, so beautiful in some cases
from us or cinematic standpoint,
even though they're on the static page,
bold, bold shots that I never would've
thought a filmmaker like, wow,
I never would have put the camera there.
You know,
how to shoot to and give them that credit.
But uh,
with Sin City,
why did you gravitate to that so
much so that you would do the,
the test and approach. Frank, who's,
I mean very well known for not wanting
his stuff to be adapted. Why did that,
like what,
what was it that got you so determined?
It was a book that I would buy
it buy over and over again.
It was one of those things that that's
when you know something means something
to you when you, and it's like,
I'm really that dumb. You know?
I literally was buying the book over
and over for like 10 years before I
realized, wait a minute, I should be
making a movie out of this. I keep,
I'm gravitating this for a reason.
Cause that style in particular,
that black and white style and I'd
wanted to do a film war for a while,
but it feel like it'd be too nostalgic.
This felt so modern postmodern Fillmore
and the style of it just was so stunning
in black and white. The absence
of information, you know,
seeing the less was so captivating,
it's like this hardly anything there
and it's amazing how little you need to
recognize the human face or a window or,
and I loved the basic quality of it.
I thought that would be so amazing as a
movie and I know that they're going to
screw it up someday.
They'll try and make a movie of Sin City
cause they're captivated and they won't
realize it's because have this because
of the visual and they'll go shoot it
like a regular movie and they'll wonder
why it sits there and doesn't have the
life that it did in the book because
they're not going to shoot it like that.
And after I did spike,
it's three on the green screen.
I went back and looking like I
usually do for my next project.
I looked through all my, my stuff that I
have and I live in this city again. I go,
Whoa, I know how to do this now
by shot this on green screen.
I could make it legit. I Bet I can make
it look just like, well let me test it.
And I,
and I'm real protective like test stage.
Not even my crew knew what I was even
shooting cause I have my own stages and
add a green screen.
So I just went and asked a few crew
members to come and I need him to show him
what I was filming. I was filming out
of the book and I staged a few shots,
took them back,
did them in Photoshop,
kind of applied it in
three d and it worked.
It was like,
it looked like you're looking at a static
image of his and suddenly it moved. Um,
and so I took it to show him
and he flipped out and I said,
this is how we're going to do it. We're
going to do it exactly like your book.
We're going to make your book
move instead of taking your book.
And and adapting that to film. We're
going to take film and adapt it to your,
to your book. So we're going to switch
it and we're not going to change it.
So cause everyone who gives you,
you hand him that book and they say,
oh well now it has to be adapted into
a screenplay and this is fine for a
graphic novel,
but it's not the same as a movie.
The wrong visual storytelling
is visual storytelling.
I don't see why this should not work if
it's just on the screen and we're going
to prove it.
And that was what I was so excited about
and everybody who got involved in it
was so excited about it.
It was just felt new and different
and fresh and vital and it,
and it got you so jazzed and I didn't
think it would even be successful because
he didn't care.
You're like,
you don't know how I can attract big
stars to this cause it's going to be so
pure and yeah, it's probably,
it's going to look so weird.
Black and white anthology,
all voiceover.
It was the three things you're supposed
to not do. Probably no one will get it.
When they see the first trailer,
they'll go to artsy or too weird,
but maybe they'll catch it
later, you know, in DVD or
whatever. I'm fine with that.
I let it be the thing,
you know,
John Carpenter's the thing and
it let it be 10 years from now,
people figured I just
really need to make it.
And then if was successful the first time,
but that might not have happened. Yeah.
It easily could have used easily.
Could have gone the other way. Yeah.
People just think it's too
weird and that's it. You
know, he was just saying sure.
Of
Vindication for me to finally
see it done. Right. So I was,
I remember when the first punisher movie
got made and announced and I fought my
parents tooth and nail to not go to
summer camp because I wanted to see this
movie so badly and like, and, and I
was such a petulant pain in the ass.
Cause then I got to summer camp and
I knew the movie was coming out.
I wouldn't see it.
And so I would send,
we were required to send
these daily letters or as
either or weekly letters home
to our parents to tell them about
summer camp and I was just bitching and
moaning and every letter he,
cause I was still not going
to see the punisher movie,
but then it came out and it was,
it was,
they didn't preserve the integrity of
the beautiful aspect of what drew me to
the comic in the first place.
So anyway, I mean Kudos to you.
I was just so thrilled.
No, it was exciting and
especially after all that,
but it felt like that kind of the thing,
it felt like it was the one is what the
fastest when we ever got going with a
vendor who had the idea to go show
frank that test. As soon as I saw it,
I literally met him in November.
I gave him the script and December
we shot the test in January,
showed it to a few actors
like Bruce Willis in that,
and we were shooting
the real film by March.
Does the fastest any Hollywood movies
ever taken off by far because it was
already written in the book and when
we weren't going adopted, you know,
really right. And the drawings
were already done. So, um, and I,
and then you'd only cast per episodes.
I would shoot the first episode would
make you work and if I didn't have another
actor like the bad guy who were Grauer,
it's like it's okay. A shooted with me.
And we were replacing me later cause
it's green screen shot him eight months
later and him and Mickey,
you'd swear they had a scene together.
He goes up and even killed the guy,
puts his hands on his face and crushes
him and they never met. You know,
things like that you can do.
You were just so excited about all
of the things that you could do,
all the possibilities,
all the people you could put in the movie.
And I would shit shut down
for a week after each story.
Short story cast the next one quickly
they would come down, we should,
they're part shut down again.
Caslin x when they'd show up.
So He'd just do it like in three
segments. It was fantastic. It's amazing.
It was the most fun
shoot. What is, uh, your,
when we were talking about starting
with Hawaii and you, you, you,
you mentioned kind of starting your day,
what does,
what does the first 60
minutes of your day look like?
Do you have any particular
kind of changes? If I don't,
if I don't go through my list of
things I want to do for the next day,
the night before, which I try to
do so that, and I have, uh, I have,
I have long lists of things to
do. Um, this is in your phone,
some of my phone and I use notes to notes
that comes with it because it's faster
if I have to open another program.
Like I never known anything and
it's got to load. That's too late.
Is the ideas out of my head already? I
need a scratch pad. That's really fast.
So here this one's called bullet lists
2015 while you have holders for the year.
No, no, this is just what I know. This
is the year I see. You just add to it.
I just keep adding to it.
And now that's the top portion
of another list called hit list,
which is a top which has three parts
it one, two and three. It's like a,
this is an offshoot of an
offshoot of an off shoot.
Every once in a while I'll go through
but really I'll put at the very top and
then I'll put some x's under it.
Stuff I need to do that day,
like things that I know I need to do.
And the middle one to just say, yeah,
the top priority thing like that was
like make a show until Ferris because I
knew I was going to see you.
So um, tell fairs with time,
learn this guitar lick that
I always wanted. I put it,
I'm going to drop that one down eventually
but at least it goes on the top right
now.
But I'll check my list to make sure I'm
not supposed to be doing something that
everyone needs to do in the morning.
I have like half waking up. Usually I,
but I like to do is try to work out
in the morning because it's just,
you usually wake up. Um, I just finished
night shooting, so I'm all three.
Your alternative? Yeah, usually I don't
go to sleep now to six in the morning.
I'm trying to nic knock it back,
really have to go to sleep to
two or three in the morning.
Sometimes four in the morning. I'll
get up around like 11, 10, 30, 11.
No matter what. You know, I just
kind of wake up and I'll go start.
And if I can get an app later
in the day, then I will. But um,
I'll go down and get some breakfast,
which is, you know, I'm allergic to eggs,
egg whites. So that went out the
dough. So it's um, I like those um,
um, plant fusion protein shakes that
are, that are plant not so tasty.
It's like 25 grams of protein or
something and one scoop. Oh my God.
So I do two scoops of that and then I'll
either have beans cause I live there.
You're being diabetic because I'm Mexican,
so shit easy.
I bake fresh beans are awesome
for like last week, a whole week.
And I use a set of rocks. He used
to love beans and rice. Um, I,
I do cauliflower rice,
so you just make rice out of
the cauliflower with Kale in it.
And I season at the same way do Spanish
rice and man you can't tell it tastes so
good and you've done it all day and eat
that. And then I'll have a, you know,
some other protein if I need to and
them and then that get me going. Um,
I'll either work out or if I have meetings
or sometimes if I just have to write
or do something,
I'll go attack,
try and knock out some things that I have
and always have something to ride them.
I didn't like for script right now.
So it's like,
usually it's something
that's more, um, you know,
pressing and I'll try and knock it out
during the day if not later under the day.
And I try and limit meetings and things
to to a couple of days so that I can
really have blocks of time to get some
of these things to hundred bucks cause I
now that I own a television network,
those are,
these things keep popping up so you can,
your,
your list is never going to be
accurate because later that day,
oh I got to look at episode two oh
seven for the, for the new season of,
from dusk till dawn and I
got to go put eyes on it.
If it's not completely a hundred percent
I'm going to have to go edit it myself,
do some editing on it.
So I got a blackout time for that and
then it'll have some other, you know,
ideas for things.
My Endo episode I gotta be editing on,
I've got to start looking at that already
and thinking about music and stuff and
score ideas and so that's
going to take its own time.
So I got to like really
jam when I start the day.
Even if I think I got a full day that's
going to be dedicated to whatever I have
on my list, five or six other things
are going to pop up, you know,
that are just as important that I
can't get away from. Yeah. So, um,
it's really just a chipping away at
everything and always trying to make, um,
I learned this and I remember
we learned this from,
but I love to take on a lot
of different things, you know,
like take on many different projects.
I mean,
I'll give you a list of the projects
that have on right now there's a lot,
but if you just chip away at each one,
you gain momentum on all of them and then
you're living your dream by end of the
week. You're living
your dream, you're that,
you're doing everything that you want
to do. You're not doing it all day,
maybe 30 minutes here,
30 minutes there,
but it's chipping away and it's gaining
momentum and it's not, you know,
just falling by the wayside.
What is, what are the hit lists?
So I just call it and it used to be called
to do lists and then I needed to make
another one to differentiate
and it's called hit list.
So likes like things I
have to do right now. Okay.
And then so then the name, it's just
kind of like everything I got to do,
I was just like recent more recent
things that I needed to do or the most
important from from the to do list.
Went to the hit list and then as
that just grew and became unwieldy,
I just took like the top section of that
and moved it to a new one and then the
top six of that and move to like a
pyramid of champagne glasses just keeps,
keeps going, spilling over
to the next level. I now,
and I try to keep a separate one
for my kids cause I'll, I'll um,
I pride myself most on
being a great father.
I have five kids and I'm applying
all this to being a father.
So I'll keep a whole list
just for them. Um, uh,
things that I want to tell him or talk
to them about or show them or do and it's
jam packed. So when they come over on the
weekends, we go through the list, boom,
boom, boom, boom, boom. And everything
that I've thought of over the week,
I've had a place to dump it and we get
it all done. So you get this really, um,
concise,
dense experience with dance experience
more than if it was just spread out,
you know, here and there you
really get to feel like you've, uh,
spend really quality time with them and
none of the ideas that you've had that
you want to share with them fly away.
So really capturing these ideas
is the most important thing.
And then did you go through your realize,
okay, this one I'll never do this one.
I'll never do,
you know,
with your to do list and stuff or it's
already taken care of itself some other
way. I don't, I don't fret too much
about stuff that I'm not getting done.
Somehow they, they always end
up figuring themselves out.
So I tend to not stress at all,
but it does wake me up at night sometimes
when I realized I gotta write that
down or I'll forget it.
I will forget and then it'll,
I'll be stressed knowing
that I forgotten something.
I don't have nowhere to
civically what it is.
Well this is why I know it's all
captured and I can get through with your
network.
What is,
what is the best way for people to check
out the content on the network? Oh Man.
Well right now we're just now
in 40 million homes, which
is amazing. After a year,
um,
we're on all the big carriers.
A lot of people don't even realize they
have us cause it wasn't something that I
had to buy extra. So they
should just look for it. So,
cause you're pointing to start
whoever, Comcast, directv, Time Warner,
Cox, um, dish. We're on sling TV now.
We're one of the few channels and
that offering where you can just buy a
subscription and you can get like
20 networks or something like that.
I'll raise one of them. And that's doing
really well for, it's a lot of people.
A lot more people have gotten
that than we thought. Um,
and then individual programs like we have,
what's it like when
you have a new network?
You don't really create new shows for
like five years or six years you use,
you just show old programming.
Right. I can't even see,
you didn't make an original show for
20 years, you know, it was just legion,
really just old license program
in American movie classics.
And we had four new shows the first year
because we had to kind of make our mark
and show people the only way people are
going to find the network does if they
heard of these shows. Oh,
director's chair. Where's that? Oh,
it's on were El ray network. What's
that? Oh, ductile. Dawn. A TV series.
Where is that again? Oh Ray. What's Rey?
And they'd have to go look
for El Rey and find it.
So the only way to really draw people
is by having programming that's only
exists there.
And we only do stuff that we can do.
Like no one could get the rights to
from dusk till dawn. They wanted it.
But Quinn and I controlled it.
Well he,
he let me do it for my own network
cause he was like, all right,
what's your networks like my
network and he loves the network.
He loves all this stuff. We show,
um, it's all curated content.
That's what's so cool is if you've got
to use licensed programming, well man,
it's what's, what's my favorite
movies? Kung Fu, you know,
John Rhe films actually film brass
knuckle Mondays, creature feature Fridays,
you know,
just licensed the best,
the coolest stuff to show people kind
of hear these are the great ones.
These are the ones that you should know
and this is why we cure rate him like
that.
So it's a real curated experience.
And then there's premier programming
and it's so fun as having a network is
sometimes you'll stumble upon an idea.
Like I was going to have five John
Carpenter movies into no may last year.
And I thought, I know John, I'll go film
him introducing each one of those films.
Little intro. So it'll be
a little original piece of
content to go with it. Well,
shit, while I'm there, you know, sit and
just setting up the mics and the camera.
I'll just shoot the shit
from about directing.
They'll call it the director's chair,
tried to do an episode of that.
And maybe that can be a show kind of like,
but John is in very forthcoming,
he's very toxic stuff down a lot
and he's always like, ah, this is,
anybody can do it. And he's, he
came, he and you've most interviews,
you read about them.
They're not at all like the show I did.
So I thought it'd be a good test.
I did the show with him and he was so
profound and so professorial and so open
that I thought, oh my God,
this is John Talking like this.
Imagine the other directors
who are already like that. Um,
friends of mine called
and said the new John.
I've never seen him talk like that before.
And I've known him 20 years, you know.
So there was something about a director
talking to another director that was
going to spark a different
third. Disarming a different
level of conversation.
And now that's one of my favorite things
to shoot and it's so quick, you know,
I'll research for about a week,
week and a half sometimes get
to rewatch all their films,
come in with like 30 pages of notes and,
and,
and ask them these great questions that
I've always wanted to know and the best
stuff comes out. Just did it. Michael
Mann when an end. George Miller one,
those are really good.
What have been some of the most uh,
surprising answers that
you've received or a
captivating answers?
Just you just never know.
I mean Semeka saying he thought he was
making the worst movie ever and Forrest
Gump,
you know those moments of darkness where
you're just like questioning everything
or that he was punched, punching,
you know, and back to the future.
Your most cut the Johnny be
good sequence cause he was like,
well it doesn't really fit.
That's what I was going to cut it
even before we even preview it.
And as soon as editor was like,
just leave it in for this free space.
He said we couldn't peel people off the
ceiling and you know, you never know.
It shows that you don't know,
and when I use an artist,
I want people to hear those stories
because when you feel like, ah,
I don't know if I'm doing it right,
these other guys seem to know no,
they don't know.
None of them know.
That's the beauty of it is
that you don't have to know.
You just got to keep moving forward.
You have to go sit down and put pen to
paper. It's not going to come to you.
If you just sit there
waiting for it to happen,
you have to act and then as soon as
you step forward, even a little bit,
it starts sweeping you away,
doesn't it? Is Flow and you're like,
how am I doing this? Then you're like,
it's not you, but you had to start.
If you don't start it as income.
Yeah. It only comes if you start,
so that's the main thing.
He just got to start.
When you think of the word successful,
who's the first person
who comes to mind for you?
Okay.
Wow, that's a good one. Successful.
So many different ways to find
the success. Yeah, that's, I mean,
I always thought my dad
was successful because he,
he was an entrepreneur and that he,
um,
he had 10 kids and he sold
cookware door to door.
And with the beauty of
that was he'd come home,
my mom would say to the kids need braces.
He could calculate how many,
how many sets of cookware he had
to sell in order to pay that.
And he'd go sell it. He wouldn't,
he knew he had a target.
If he worked at a job where he got just
the same amount of money, no matter what,
you'd be screwed.
But because he could go just sell harder,
sell somebody on something. It's really
strange. But you know, have five brothers,
none of them work for anyone.
They're all entrepreneurs.
They all have their own businesses.
They'll either know,
my brother has his own pharmacies
already got two pharmacies.
One of my other brothers
sells life insurance and
he's like the top salesman in
the country.
But other brothers sells real estate.
No one wanted to work for anyone else.
Partly,
I think it's just part of in the DNA
that you just don't want to be under
someone else's thumb. It's
kind of why, you know, if I
come up against guild roles,
I disliked suddenly get abrasive.
I don't know why, but it's just,
it's just cause it's in the DNA.
You just can't work for somebody else.
And I noticed that in my kids too.
So you'll narrow it to be able to
know to work with somebody else.
I'll try to teach them early how to
innovate thrown jobs because they're gonna
get more satisfaction out of writing
their own ticket. As busy as I am.
It's kind of fun to go
back and look and go, wow,
I created every job that I have
right now. I've, I my own problem.
I have all this work to do
because I created every down.
But no one's asking me for this.
I'm asking myself to deliver this stuff
cause I've put that responsibility on
myself.
That's a great freedom.
That's feels like a great success to
be able to live the life you want,
be able to carve out so
much time for your family.
And relationships and people can still
come and say you're the busiest person I
know in new, Oh wow. I'm not really,
I'm really finding a way
to put it all together.
I really learned that from my father.
So I think immediately people that
I knew and I still read his little
entrepreneur magazines he had and
thought that sounds so cool. Wow.
So I'm going to put video games machines
in the back of a truck and drove it
around to the balls and
made money doing that.
I mean I was always inspired by these
entrepreneurial stories of people finding
another way to go instead of following
everybody else and finding success and
happiness. So, um,
several people to me are those who kind
of put it all together because if you,
you can have business success and job
security and be miserable and your
personal life or have that always fallen
apart or some crisis always happening
and I'm eating it up, I'm loving it,
you know? And I got that from my father.
We had such great relationships
in the family and it spilled over.
My kids now are getting older and I love
when they call me in six me and say,
Dad,
can we talk?
And they want advice and you get to
go be dad and you give them all the
strategies you've learned and
now they make sense to them.
Even though you've told them as they
grow up now they can apply it and you're
just like, wow, this,
I wish I learned this when I was their
age and I look how far I have not knowing
it.
Imagine how far they could go and it's
really been able to give that gift back
to people and your children
and the next generation.
That's been the most fulfilling,
the most exciting.
The most stuff I journal is about
that. You know, like wow, really,
really profound stuff.
It's like shit I just learned last week.
I'm getting applied to them and they're
getting to learn it and they're like
jumping ahead like 10
steps. It's like, wow.
If you could have a billboard anywhere,
uh,
could have text, visuals, whatever. Where
would you put it in? What would it say?
It's like kind of questions,
but when I would do interviews to have
it asked the same question over and over
and you get so bored with them, but then
somebody gives you an original question,
you're stumped because you're like,
I'm not used to answering that question.
Let's go back to the easy ones.
If I could.
What's the best answer
you've heard for that?
Oh, what's the best answer
I've heard for that? Let's see,
I might be conflating the two answers.
I interviewed generally general Stan
Mcchrystal recently a four star general.
He used to run Jay sock.
So basically all the special
forces in Afghanistan and Iraq. Uh,
and it might've been his favorite quote.
I might be confusing the two answers,
but he said the, the, uh, the purpose
of life is a life with purpose.
I was quite a big fan of
that. Uh, Brian Johnson also,
I started coming called brain tree and
sold it for $800 million to in cash to
Ebay. Uh, had a good answer to this
and I'm blanking on at the moment,
but what are your thoughts?
Um, that was one that I did that I said
earlier. He said, oh, I like that quote.
That's one that I say a lot to people
is, is don't be a, don't follow the herd,
you know, code. And it's easier
when people are visually can see it.
But I'm pointing one direction and I
say that even when you hear me talking
about the network and the network sizzle,
I'll say, if everyone's going that way,
you know,
like to the left,
we're going to go this way to the right
because that's how you stumble upon new
things by just going to down the
unbeaten path, you know, and it's, uh,
it's always rewarding. Any,
anything in any way you choose.
And it's just business and
life in general and everything.
You just go that way and you follow your,
and really cultivating your instincts,
cultivating that instinct so
that you can always rely on that.
Because if you always have to rely
on the advice of other people,
which is all good, when they're not
there, you're screwed. You know,
you gotta be able to follow that,
that inner voice,
that inner voice and cultivate that
and know when it serves you and when it
doesn't serve you trust that it's
not serving you just at the moment,
but it's over the long haul. It's soon
as it's actually in your best interest.
And if you have that kind of faith
and then you're never stressed,
you're never worried about anything.
One of the things I was teaching,
my son was very upset about
something and I'm saying,
I'm going to tell you some secret life.
You never have to be upset about anything.
Everything is for her purpose.
You just failed your drivers
test and you were all pissed off.
I couldn't be happier.
I'd rather you fail with a teacher and
take it a hundred more times than to go
fail in front of a cop or turn the wrong,
make that same mistake and hit somebody.
Now you're 10 days in jail. Right.
You know, I can't even think
of a negative reason why you,
you failing that test is a bad thing.
You see how you some really,
definitely you look at it and the way you
look at it as so important and you can
have a positive attitude and look at it.
Well let me see what
I can learn from this.
Why would you ever get upset
about anything? And he was
like, wow, so much sense.
I'm so excited about that as a damn.
I got to make sure I apply that in myself
though cause I'm sure I'm still get
upset about something and then there's
no reason why you upset why something
didn't go according to plan.
It might be for good reason,
but this let's make something out
of that. You know, let's take,
let's take the good out of that.
I've always,
I still tried to apply that all the time.
Never worry when a friend of mine came
to visit me on the set, we're shooting,
it's a television season finale
for dusk till dawn. It's huge.
I mean I had them add more and more stuff
to it. I wanted it to be big, bonkers,
more stunts and ever really deliver and
he couldn't believe that I'm sitting
behind the monitor playing guitar,
which I do on the set.
I play the guitar because it keeps me
from pacing and it keeps me from getting
riled up or stressed. And I'm also writing
score at the same time. Subliminally.
Sometimes it ends up being the score.
People go, what are you playing? You know,
I like that. Oh, I don't know.
Maybe it's the theme man.
And we recorded him real quick and
I would be so stressed, you know,
doing this if I was like, no, no, there's
no reason to be stressed. Why? Well,
something might go wrong.
So if it goes wrong,
you figure out how to make it right.
It's really, I mean, you being stressed,
is it going to be getting any better?
In fact, you want to be cool breeze,
so otherwise you're not gonna be
able to think of very, very well.
Why not enjoy the shoot?
Why you might be maniac.
And I realized how it's totally the
opposite of what you would expect on
something that fast.
Well,
you have to shoot that quick and every
dollar counts that you would be playing
the guitar kind of softly in between
Susan and everybody and keeping the
creativity flowing in between takes.
That's why I have my actors paint a team,
actors how to paint, um, in between
takes because sometimes they'll say,
I don't know how to pay me. Like, no,
that's bullshit. You new creative already.
You can paint just as easily
as you can act or do anything.
And I'm going show you here,
pick any colors,
I'll show you different ways you can
apply. You apply it any way you want.
And I'm gonna take a photograph of you
and character. We're going to transfer,
align, drying it. Mostly your painting
will come through in the face.
Maybe we'll smoke out the eyes or
something. It'll be done. It'll be a wrap.
Present us cocreating a character of
yourself to show him to blow you away.
And I'd love to see them and
they're blown away because,
and they just trust it now because
they've seen the other ones.
Lady Gaga has Bruce
Willis is when they go,
like obviously this guy knows what he's
talking about so and they'd be in there
for free and it's easier now.
Everybody already knows they can do it
because they see everyone else does it
and you don't have to train as
much. It's really cool. I mean,
people don't have to unlearn anything and
you'd teach them a new thing like that.
It's a relief to know that you
don't have to be hesitant and um,
and then you want them to bring that back
to the set because usually you'd call
cut, they have to go to their trailer,
they sit there and not being creative,
they're on the phone or whatever.
Then you're having them come back to
the set and suddenly be creative again.
This keeps them in a creative flow.
It's whether they're thinking about
solving problems with a different side of
their creative grain that they're
not even utilizing while act. It's,
it's amazing. It's a whole other side.
So when they come back to the set,
you can tell there's a
problem here with a table.
The cards slide all the way
across and it's not going to work.
You figure it out in two seconds cause
you've already been solving creative
problems and the other room much more
like what color to use and how much
breaststroke to use so that this is like,
oh well this is simple hair.
Just toss them anywhere you want and we'll
erase it there and make it land where
we want and we're, we'll put them in
the place and that'd be fine. I love it.
It's like no one really smart.
That's very clever.
I want to be respectful of your time.
I'm having so much fun.
I can lose track of time,
but I would love to ask some questions
from fans who have submitted things.
Visa, did you do that? You, uh, did
you, how did you get the questions?
So I gathered the questions by
pulling them on Twitter and Facebook,
but do you send out an announcement on
Twitter and Facebook saying Robert's
coming in and then they said,
if you could ask anything?
I think I usually phrase it one of two
ways. I'll say either a, if you could ask,
you know, at Rodriguez anything, what
would you like to ask him? For instance,
I might phrase it that way and I think
that that might've been when I put out
and uh,
then I will get answers back on both
Twitter and Facebook that the beauty of
Facebook, and I've also done this via
something called Google moderator,
which is going to get shut down,
but people on Facebook and it can,
it can up vote the questions that like,
so you basically get to see at
the top five most popular. Uh,
so this question is from Mike.
Les,
what do most people not
realize, not realize, excuse me,
about filmmaking until
they become filmmakers?
How much work it is.
I put out a book called rebel without
a crew to demystify the process,
but also to say,
here is a 10 minute film school.
All you need to know is in 10 minutes.
It's not true, but it is true in a way.
It said,
you just got to start.
I didn't put in there the mind
numbing work that goes into it,
that the soul crushing lows,
you'll experience trying to realize
your vision because I know you'll figure
that out on the way.
And I know that it'll really,
we'll separate those from her going to
be doers and were those who are donors.
You know, you're going to either figure
out this is for me or this isn't for me.
It's good it cause it's really, I remember
my short film bedhead short films,
eight minutes to credits are going
and finally finished the credits.
I was tears in my eyes.
I was so spent,
and it's a little short
films so you can imagine how,
how much it takes out of you to birth
something you know from originally from
your gut. You know, it really takes
a lot. You can never explain that.
So I don't try. I just Kinda say send
people on their way, inspire him,
let him go and they'll
figure it out pretty quick.
They'll come back with this
look in their eye like,
what the hell did I just go through?
And they'll either be invigorated by
that in some way or inspired by that or
they'll just know that's not for them.
And that's kind of what
will separate them.
I wouldn't want to tell people
this is too much for you.
Let them decide that you know, this is
really tough to go on. This could really,
you could spend a lot of time and money
on something that's never going to go
off the ground.
I let them figure that out and they'll,
they'll figure that out pretty quick.
This is from cure as Sen.
Uh, what do you have in common with
the main characters in your movies?
Anything from family structure to outfit,
etc. Yeah,
the movies always when you
write an original character
very much as a reflection
of who you are in a lot of ways.
And I'm,
I'm all out of the characters
on the girls. I'm the men. Um,
there's this pieces of me and all of them,
this pieces of yourself that kind of,
it's kind of why sometimes I like to do
movies that I didn't write just to get
out of yourself for a while cause then
you'll tend to write some of their
characters.
They're always kind of rule breakers are
always kind of doing their own thing.
Um,
and they always have this sort of,
this loner type type attitude.
But they're there,
they realize the greater cause and what
they can bring to it from machete to the
Desperado to even the spike is a spike.
It's probably the closest to my family.
I really wanted to make a
movie based on my family,
the experience of growing up with 10 kids.
So my uncle was a Gregorio,
it'll degas. He was a special
agent for the, um, for the, uh,
FBI brought down to a top 10 criminals.
And um,
he,
uh,
by based Gregorio Cortez played 20 Bandura
on him and my brother and my sisters
names are in there as the two brothers
and sisters. My uncle Felix when uncle,
it's like my whole family is
told in the spike in movie.
So that was very satisfying to kind of
be able to tell your family story hidden
in a spy film.
But it's really how we got along with
my siblings and the whole dynamic and my
family, uh, done in a
way. Sometimes it's very,
it's very obvious like that and
other times it's kind of just hidden.
Just you know, everybody from the
Johnny Depp character where you know,
he rigged the games constantly.
So he wins.
My kids say that's me all the time that
line up. He says, Hey, it's not cheating.
It's creative sportsmanship. That's what
my kids always say when I, when death,
not cheating instance,
create a sportsmanship when I beat him at
a game cause Ben some role in my favor,
they're entertained by that.
They're not, don't feel bad.
They actually look forward to the hell.
I'm going to bend the rules.
Uh,
this is for Lawrence Fabro I
think rot sounds like Jon Favreau.
He was on this podcast as well.
Really Fun guys cause he contributed some
questions to you. Is a great guy. Yeah.
Great Guy. Uh, what do you
geeking out on right now?
What do you think is fucking cool
kicking down on written?
Gosh,
I think of a good answer is it's
so many different little things.
Like I just figured out that there were
all these other sounds were available.
All these other patches were available
to me did I never noticed before on the
amp settings on my pro tools setting for
at any function that I didn't like at
first because it replaced one that didn't
get upgraded with a new system and I
was just pissed.
I was trying to record some music and,
and get a sound that I was looking for
and in this thing seem really limited and
then suddenly I found a button I didn't
know existed because I never read the
instructions and this whole
menu of things that are locked,
I have to go and lock them and brought
it to go pay some price but it's just so
tantalizing and go,
oh my God,
what sounds are going to be there that
I can go some geeking out over something
that um,
I guess to summarize,
when I first started I would take the
two VCRs and hook them together and edit
my movies that way.
And I would use every function,
milk it for everything that it could do.
If people would be shocked at what I
was able to get these machines to do,
cause I would take any little function
that was a positive and I would use it in
a way my movies now,
it's completely the opposite.
You only scratching the surface of
every one of these applications.
You could go down the wormhole and
stayed there for quite a while.
Just trying to figure out all the things
that each one of these programs is
capable of.
It's mind boggling and you're never
going to take full advantage of them.
It's the complete
opposite of how I grew up,
where I was milking everything
for what it was worth. And now,
no matter how deep I go into it,
it can do so much more.
And it drives you crazy where there's
just not enough hours in the day.
It's just not enough hours in the day
to kick out or things stuff with my kids
just, you know, the gaming world.
We'd love playing games together.
Any favorite game to play together?
Well we still kind of playing some of
the old games again and again we're
looking forward to um,
we were playing actually all the old halos
again cause they grew up. Some of the,
a lot of the stuff we do is the, is
the uh, the stylistic stuff cause they,
they come over to the house and they
want to relive the old days and they love
that. Some of our favorite old games are
now available. Like even Mario 64 weeks.
They all grew up on is now
available, you know, better,
better quality HD st with all the Halos
can go back and play all the halal
levels, you know, uh, from one
on that they learned on me.
I'm really clear and crystal when
big screen. So that's been fun.
What are filmmakers do you feel getting
better at and what are they getting
worse at?
We can narrow that that a little bit.
Let's just not say the people who were
out there at the prime of their career,
but people who are just starting out,
uh,
what are they getting better at and
what are they getting worse then
what I think,
um,
I think is great about what filmmakers
are doing today is utilizing just how
quickly they use, utilize new technology
and new ways of communication. You know,
how you broke in the industry when I
started so much different than how you do
it now. When did the guys,
I'm from Ecuador came in,
worked on dusk till dawn.
He, uh, he said, yeah,
there was no production down there.
I read your book and I went and made a
little short film and I put it on the
Internet and within,
you know,
a day it went viral and the studios
were flying me up and he got to make the
evil dead movies and it was
a fit. Alvarez, the remake.
And then I got him to direct one of my
episodes and he was like, wow. Yeah,
I was inspired by that.
You just did it with nothing.
And I was able to go do it in Ecuador.
There was no film industry down
there and we just did it. And,
and I was shocked that I could just put
it on the Internet and they get noticed
by Hollywood. I mean it's just, no,
and they'll film festival and that cut
cut all that. It actually just from,
from another country sends something in,
spreads everywhere,
gets them noticed.
You know,
I've seen a lot of people do that now
where they shoot proofs of concepts of
whole things and then they put them out
for everyone to see and they can make a
deal that way with the studio. It goes,
this guy knows what he's doing. I mean,
just really clever way. I think
that's, that's really great. Um,
how has it gotten worse? Gosh,
I don't know. Were skills
that are getting lost? Oh,
skills.
Well,
I mean I was lucky at and
that I got to cut on film. Oh,
I got to see all the limitations of
the old system. At least kids today,
they just learn the new system.
So they're often running.
But I saw the old system and saw just
how much better the new systems where,
I mean that was the only guy cutting
digitally on the Sony Lot when I did
desperado though all the other
editors were afraid of it. You know,
they were just afraid that
it was going to replace them.
The same with digital photography.
I was first to start shooting digitally.
You know, dps. We're afraid that was
going to be to their job. You know,
they'll realize it's just another
tool. It's not, the job isn't,
isn't the old technology. The
technology is not the art form, right.
The manipulation and moving images can
happen on a machine or it can happen by
cutting film.
It's not that.
It's not the technology that is the
art form and people don't realize,
I think kids today, it's a good thing
is that they know that, you know,
they just know,
they just accept any new thing and
they'll new tool and they'll use it.
They're not a slave to tradition.
The way the older generation was.
That held stuff back because you would
see people shooting digital cameras way
before they shot digital cameras and
Hollywood people were 10 years ahead of
Hollywood. Always so slow.
That's why I don't live there.
And that's why we much more
cutting edge and in Austin,
just cause we're not have any
tradition around us saying, no,
you're not supposed to do it that way.
We just rethink it. Right. It's like why?
Why? Why are you even doing it that way?
That doesn't make any sense. This new way.
Makes Sense. So I really, um,
I think of anything people, uh,
what people do wrong is when they don't,
um,
embrace a new technology early enough,
like in the know dps, you know,
directors of photography,
we were wrong not to try to embrace
digital photography early enough so it can
get in there and help try and
define what the look of it would be,
how the systems would be built.
Now it's too late.
Now they're all switching
over and complain about it.
But it's too late now because it's been
adopted and you weren't anywhere near
you and stuck your head in the sand stage.
You went and stuck your head in the sand
while everybody else was using the end
developing.
And now he,
now he's got a stuck with it and you
could have developed a whole new way of
photographing movies and human stuck
your head in the sand for 10 years.
It makes zero sense. So instead
I was like, I told him and I,
and that's why it has a hot dog holder
next to it because that was important to
me.
Uh,
what advice last last two questions.
What advice would you give to
your 30 year old self? Wow.
30 year old self.
I see that I have anything figured out,
but 30 got know any of the advice
that I've been giving my kids.
I wish I had heard at 30, 35, 40. Um,
18. I mean, I um, I always
learn new new techniques,
new things,
new ways to do things better.
And I always try to apply them and I
always wish I just knew more back then
being just more self aware. Um, but then
again, sometimes you look back and you go,
being naive and not knowing
was probably the best gift.
Sometimes you know too much,
you know,
you know too much and then you stop
doing things. It's better not to know.
You know, I try to, I always try to be,
you know, there's just that example of,
you know, you ask a bunch of
little kids who can do anything,
who could be the president, who
can write an opera, who can paint,
who can be a filmmaker and they'll raise
their hand because they don't know.
They all just believe they can and he
has the same kids in 10 years and the
hands started going down. No
life experience. They just
start, stopped believing.
I always try to be that kid who has
his hand up in the air. It's like,
can you write a score to a movie with a
hundred piece orchestra even though you
don't read or write music? Sure. I still
do it. And you do it and you're like,
how the fuck did I do that? Well,
because you were being creative.
The technical part of the was
just 10% you can fudge that.
Some of the best musicians don't
know how to read or write music.
You can fudge all of that stuff.
I mean,
you know how to be creative if you
keep your hand up. Can you do this?
Can you do that? Yeah. Yeah.
Who is it? How do I know? I
can't until I try it. Okay.
Maybe I'm not that good at it,
but I can still do it and I can
probably learn to be better.
And if I surround myself by masters,
I'll get better a lot faster. Um,
so, um, yeah,
I guess I would just go back and follow
my own good advice more than anything.
Sometimes I have, I think we all
inherently know what we're supposed to do.
We just don't always do
it. Um, so I think, uh,
if we were just to open our mouths
in a way to go teach somebody,
we would end up giving some very profound
advice that we would be writing down
and going, I need to go make sure I'm
doing that. I remember someone said to me,
or I might've read this, you know,
wisdom is taking your own advice. It is,
it totally is. Because sometimes you
give advice, but that's, but that's why,
cause they advice doesn't
really come from you. You know,
when you go to open your mouth and
you move forward in a positive way to
enlighten someone, the enlightenment
comes and it's not from you,
it just coming through you.
So you need to write that down cause
it's as much for you as it is for them.
It's why I love teaching because I
know I'll learn more teaching than um,
then from my students because
it's not coming from me. Yeah.
The ask,
I would like you to,
if you could make one ask or
request of people listening to this,
what would it be?
If I can make one ask.
Oh,
besides look for the El Rey network in
any of the programming that's on there.
Oh,
it asks that you just try and live as
creatively as possible because that's the,
that's the unknown. That's the
gift you can bring to the table.
That could change everything.
Even if you don't think you're creative.
Everyone inherently is creative and
there's people who block themselves
immediately by saying, oh,
I'm not creative. And um,
well of course you're not going to be
creative if that's your belief in who you
are.
So far.
Apply creativity and you'll see into
everything and you'll see you just become
more creative because you're applying.
It's everything.
Everything is an opportunity to
be creative. I'm creative all day.
There's nothing I do that doesn't
involve creativity from making a meal to
satisfy my kids and had interest is way,
it's creative right there.
I'm going to figure out a rice dish
that's not going to be rice is going to be
tasting that they're going to crave,
that's going to be good for them.
That's creativity in itself.
And it's nutrition.
You're gonna really apply
creativity to everything.
And just the Games we play when
we were stuck at the airport,
you're being creative. You know, how you
journal things, how you cross reference,
how you present things to them, how
you, um, inspire your crew, hiring,
inspire you or other people around you
have inspire yourself. It's all creative.
And if you say you're not creative,
look how much you're missing out on
just because you've told yourself that.
So I think creativity is one of the
greatest gifts that were born with it.
Some people don't cultivate that.
They don't realize could be applied
to literally everything in their life.
I found out that the most fulfilled,
happiest, most productive. When I'm happy,
when I'm creative and that's when I'm,
I'm sending my best.
So I try to do that 24 hours
a day, 24, seven, be creative,
take everything creatively. This is
an opportunity and would to be here,
sit down and be creative with you.
Be Creative in how we presented ideas,
how we got these ideas out
to the audience. And a,
and this was a full exercise
in creativity. So I'm,
I'm about to go meet with my God daughter
and go try to be creative and figure
out how she can learn some skills she
needs to learn and she's a little behind
and you go, this is an opportunity to
creatively kind of inspired and do stuff.
You know, you constantly are
using creativity all the time.
I um, I love what you do. Uh,
people should also check out your Texas
barbecue recipe. You have instruction.
It's fantastic. Oh yeah, that's sin city
breakfast tacos. Did you ever see the ice?
That was really good. Breakfast
Tacos as well. We show the uh,
the time on the,
on the screen when they're still cutting.
It's like 4:36 AM I love what
you put out in the world self.
Everybody. Stay naive, keep a journal,
be creative because whether you,
whatever you were doing in your
life, uh, you have that opportunity.
And where can people find you online?
Find more about what you're
doing on Twitter here. I'm
an at Rodriguez on Twitter,
I'm on El Rey network.com.
We're about to start a
whole digital arm of that.
We're this segment called the people's
network and people will be able to send
in their own films, short films,
ways to participate with a network,
become part of the network and
create content in a really cool way.
Sometimes they'd come all
the way to trouble maker
studios and we just had three
creators. They're getting to use
all the sets, all the actors,
all while we were shooting does.
And it gets so inspired because their
list of things that they have access to
suddenly jumped
a little Richie is list of what they used
to have suddenly jumped and they were
able to, and it was a cool experiment.
We're going to do that a lot more and um,
and a lot of things they didn't really,
the digital side of El Ray network now
that we've had the brand is really going
to be where people can participate
in ways that they don't get to in a
traditional network. And that
leverage that with, you know,
they were in 40 million homes,
it's going to be pretty awesome.
So we're excited about that.
Oh,
and next year I'm going to be doing him
another $7,000 movie with no crew and
then there's other people are going to
do it too for that, for that same thing.
We'll have an announcement about them.
They speak. Great. Well I'll, I'll,
whenever it's ready, I will
share that as well. So, uh, guys,
hope you enjoyed this as much as I did
for show notes, links to everything,
El Ray network,
everything that we discussed in the show.
Just got a four hour work week.com forward
slash podcast. And until next time,
thank you for listening. I want to add
and you can cut it in there somewhere.
Yeah I saw someone who just thank
you for what you do because uh,
demystifying the process so that others
could jumpstart their lives in ways that
they thought,
you know,
we didn't have access to something
that I've just always loved doing.
I've done consistently to the book,
to my DVD commentary,
to my special 10 minute film
schools just constantly doing it.
When I saw you doing that in this realm
and in all areas and so many areas,
I always wanted to meet you cause I
thought it was a very kinship in which you
do,
which is real gift that you give people
by putting yourself out there and giving
them, people always say, why are
you giving away all the secrets?
Like it won't cause you'll come up with
more secrets and I give the little way
and it's because I would have wanted
to know that you know, me as a student,
as a film lover and someone who felt
like I was outside of the industry not
being able to ever get in,
would have wanted to know
there was a door, there were,
there was a method or there
was something that I, it's,
I would have appreciated that someone
telling me that. So that's why I do it.
And I'm sure you're the same way.
You just constantly looking for that
juice and when Ian, how can I get it?
And then you go and you
give that gift to people.
So I think that's wonderful what you do
and that's why people are here listening.
Thanks man. Really means a lot. So,
well they will do round two some time.
Thanks man.
All right, thanks. Hey guys,
this is Tim again. Just a few more
things before you take off. Number one,
this is five bullet Friday.
Do you want to get a short email from me?
Would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every Friday that provides a
little morsel of fun before the weekend
and five bullet Friday is a very short
email where I share the coolest things
I've found or that I've been pondering
over the, that could include favorite
new albums that I've discovered.
It could include Gizmos and gadgets
and all sorts of weird shit that I've
somehow dug up in the other
world of the esoteric as I do.
It could include favorite articles that
I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance,
and it's very short.
It's just a little tiny bite of goodness
before you head off for the weekend.
So if you want to receive that,
check it out.
Just go to four hour work week.com that's
four hour work week.com all spelled
out and just drop in your email and you
will get the very next one and if you
sign up, I hope you enjoy it. This
episode is brought to you by 99 designs,
your one stop shop for all
things graphic design related.
I've used 99 designs for everything
from banner ads to book covers,
including sketches and mock ups
that led to the four hour body,
which later became number
one year times number one,
Wall Street Journal and the brainstorming.
A lot of it took place with designers
from around the world and here's how it
works. Whether you need a t
shirt, a business card, a website,
an APP thumbnail,
whatever it might be,
you submit that project and
designers from around the world.
We'll send you sketches
and mock ups and designs.
You choose your favorite and you have an
original that you love or you get your
money back.
It's that straight forward.
And many of you who are listening have
already used it and created some amazing
things that I'll be sharing it in
the future. But in the meantime,
if you want to see some
of my competitions,
some of the book covers as
well as get a free $99 upgrade,
go to 99 designs.com forward slash Tim,
that's 99 designs.com forward slash.
Tim this episode is brought to you by
Athletic Greens. I get asked all the time,
if you could all use one supplement,
what would it be?
And my answer is
inevitably Athletic Greens,
it is your all in one
nutritional insurance.
I recommended it in the four hour body,
did not get paid for that and I
travel with it to avoid getting sick.
I take it in the mornings to
ensure optimal performance.
It just covers all my basis.
If I can't get what I need through whole
food meals throughout the rest of the
day, and you can get 50 oh my
gosh, 50% off. Yes, 50% off.
If you go to athletic greens.com forward
slash Tim that's athleticgreens.com
forward slash Tim, check it out.
It's tasty, but more important,
it will help you not screw up when
you're doing your nutritional plannings.
For me, it just covers the
basis, takes a load off my mind,
puts a lot in my body and check it out.
athleticgreens.com forward slash and Tim,
if you want more of the Tim Ferriss show,
you can subscribe to the podcast on iTunes
or go to for our blog.com f o u r h o
U R B l o g.com where you'll
find an award winning blog,
tons of audio and video interview stories
with people like Warren Buffett and
Mike Shinoda from Lincoln Park,
the books plus much, much more.
Follow Tim on twitter@twitter.com
slash t Ferris.
That's t f e R R,
I s s or on Facebook at
facebook.com/tim Ferris.
Until next time,
thanks for listening.